Stammhörer und Stammhörerinnen werden es wissen. An jedem letzten Mittwoch im Monat das Chaos Radio hier bei Fritz im Studio der Chaos Computer Club, beziehungsweise nicht ganz alle, sondern eine Auswahl. Einige vom Chaos Computer Club und Mikrofon Johnny. Ich begrüße euch bei diesem Computer-Blumen hier bei Fritz. Es geht nicht immer nur um Computer, es geht um allgemeine Themen, zu dem was man so als neue Medien bezeichnet. Heute als kleine Überschrift heißt es MP3 für die Augen. Was sich dahinter verbirgt, erklären wir euch gleich. Und wer diese Sendung kennt, der weiß, die weiß, dass zu Beginn dieser lustigen Gesprächsrunde immer der Mikrofon-Check steht, der uns immer alle besonders beglückt. Chaos Computer Club ist im Studio und DJ Claude legt auf für uns die ganzen drei Stunden im Hintergrund an. Das heißt Chaos Radio bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat und vom CCC sind heute hier Martin, Christian, Andy und Andreas. Wir fangen mal links mit Martin an, mach mal Check Check.
Null eins.
Super, funktioniert großartig, Christian. Ja, klingt auch gut und jetzt geht's wahrscheinlich bergab mit dem anderen Mikro.
Zwei, drei.
Siehste, ich wusste es.
Das ist scheiße, warte mal.
Nee, ist schon viel besser jetzt.
Wunderbar.
Ganz großartig, es funktioniert. Kommt schon was? An Musik, ne? Warum hör ich nix? Ich hör noch nix. Das filmen wir gleich noch raus. Irgendwann muss was kommen. Du kannst schon mal erzählen. Martin, willst du ein bisschen anfangen, worum es heute geht? Wir haben am Anfang der Sendung gesagt, MP3 für die Augen. Das haben wir natürlich bewusst gewählt, das Motto. Denn MP3 sagt wahrscheinlich inzwischen jedem was. Digitales Audio-Format, das in aller Munde in allen Zeitschriften ist. Und wir werden uns aber heute nicht nur um eure Ohren kümmern, sondern auch um die Augen.
Ja, also erstmal guten Abend liebe Zuhörer an den digitalen Endgeräten und an den analogen Endgeräten. Das Thema der heutigen Sendung lautet Legal, digital, scheißegal, das deutsche Fernsehen der Zukunft. Ich übergebe. Dich?
Was heißt übrigens?
Also, was machen wir denn? MP3, warte mal, warte mal.
Also, wir haben euch sozusagen, wir haben uns ziemlich vorbereitet zur Abwechslung mal. Und erhofft mir, wir beschäftigen uns mal zur Abwechslung mit digitalem Fernsehen, weil digitales Fernsehen und Internet, das wird sowieso irgendwann eins. Und das heißt, auch Fernsehen haben wir überhaupt nicht leiden können. Ich gehöre zu der Fraktion. So lohnt es sich doch, medienpolitisch zum Beispiel sich das Ganze mal anzugucken. Und deswegen fangen wir, glaube ich, mal an mit einer kleinen Geschichte des digitalen Fernsehens in Deutschland. Derzeit noch ohne musikalische Untermalung. Die könnt ihr euch ja selber machen.
Also, die Geschichte des digitalen Fernsehens beginnt irgendwann mal vor ein paar Jahren. Könnt ihr euch erinnern, Leo Kirch, 1996, erste Übertragung vom Hockenheim Ring auf sechs Kameras. Das Ganze auf der D-Box. Und die D-Box war die erste Setterbox in Deutschland.
Also vielleicht erst mal fangen wir mal ganz unten an, die Setz-Dauf-Kiste.
Ja, genau, erzähl doch mal was.
Die Setz-Dauf-Kiste ist eine kleine schwarze Kiste, die unter das Fernsehgerät kommt.
Über, über. Z-Top.
Aber man kann den Fernseher auch drauf stellen. Na ja, gut, Matsch ist sie ohnehin. Aber über den Inhalt dieser Boxen reden wir gleich. Also es gibt da kleine schwarze Kisten, die kann man sich zusätzlich zu seinem Fernsehgerät dann auch hinstellen. Und dann kann man etwas mehr als die normalen Programme, die ja analog ausgestattet werden, empfangen, nämlich digitale. Die sind allerdings nicht, wie die Analogen einfach frei im Sinne von Kanal einstellen läuft, kann man gucken, sondern da gibt es noch so ein bisschen Sicherheit drumrum, da gibt es noch die theoretisch zu zahlenden Nutzungsgebühren und da gibt es nicht zuletzt den Traum von jemanden, der Leo Kirch heißt, der glaubt, er wird damit stinkend reich. Im Moment ist er damit erst mal stinkend arm geworden.
Eine Milliarde im Spiegel diese Woche. Eine Milliarde hat er damit Verlust gemacht. Kirch war der erste und das ist ganz interessant. Kirch ist nämlich wirklich ein Vorreiter im digitalen Fernsehen in Deutschland. Er hat sich nämlich einfach getraut im Alleingang gegen alle, gegen ARD, ZDF und Bertelsmann, sprich die damalige MMBG, eine D-Box zu bauen mit Nokia und zu sagen, das ist es, das digitale Fernsehen, ihr seid mir zu lahm. Und hat damit alle anderen verärgert. Und es ist halt vielleicht ganz interessant, wer momentan im digitalen Fernsehen in Deutschland das Sagen hat, nämlich Leo Kirch mit seinem Monopol und wie es dazu gekommen ist. Und das liegt halt an zwei Gründen im Grunde. Er hat nämlich seine Plattform auf den Markt gebracht und er hat sie erstmal dicht gemacht, das heißt, proprietäre Standards geschaffen. Proprietär meint irgendwie, kein anderer kann digitales Fernsehen senden, was auf seiner D-Box empfangen wird. Und dafür hat er halt eben auch noch so einen Conditional Access eingeführt, so eine Verschlüsselung namens E-Deto. Und mit diesen beiden Sachen hat Kirch es einfach geschafft, dass neben ihm keiner hochkommen konnte. Und was hat Bertelsmann gemacht seitdem? Was hat Murdoch seitdem gemacht? Wie versuchen sie jetzt Kirch zu kriegen?
Man kann sich das ungefähr so vorstellen, dass digitales Fernsehen nicht nur eine neue Technologie ist, sondern im Grunde genommen haben da gleichzeitig noch ganz andere Leute auf einmal die Macht über die Sender. Und da liefern sie sich gerade die Schlachten Kirchwahrheit sehr schnell und hat seinen Kram erstmal an den Markt gedrückt. Das rechnet sich zwar auch nicht. Premiere und DF1 sind ja jetzt gerade seit ein paar Wochen verschmolzen. Aber auch das macht erst mal Verluste. Und jetzt stehen sie aber alle in den Startlöchern, weil sie denken, da ist die Zukunft. Und da kommen dann jetzt die Bertelsmänner ins Spiel. Und auch ein paar andere. Was wiederum, und das sollte man glaube ich noch erwähnen, das Ganze hängt ja mit dem Kabelnetz zusammen.
Ja, mach mal nicht zu schnell. Also was man kennt oder was man kannte, war DF1. Das war eben das, was irgendwie versucht hat, diese DF1-Boxen zu verkaufen. Und irgendwie hat das keiner so richtig gekauft. Und es hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Dann gab es noch Premiere und gibt es noch Premiere. Das ist ja Analog TV noch. Und wird jetzt abgelöst durch Premiere Digital TV. Premiere Digital TV ist tatsächlich Premiere. Man muss es so erklären. Kirch hatte keine Abonnenten. Premiere hatte 1, 6 Millionen Abonnenten. Und Kirch und Bertelsmann haben gemeinsam Premiere betrieben. Analog. Jetzt haben Kirch und Bertelsmann versucht, Premiere zusammen zu betreiben. Also Premiere digital zusammen zu betreiben. Nein, das hieß damals noch Premiere und verboten wurde, dass von Karel van Miert, diesem EU-Kommissar, der gesagt hat, eine gemeinsame Kirch-Bertelsmann-Premiere-Plattform gibt es nicht, weil dadurch die Konkurrenz im deutschen Fernsehen irgendwie ausgeschlossen wäre. Also auf der einen Seite Kirch mit seinen Senderketten, Sat.1, was hat er noch, Kabel 1, Pro7 natürlich irgendwie, sein Sohn, Thomas Kirch, der jetzt eingemeindet wurde ins Familienunternehmen. Und auf der anderen Seite RTL, RTL 2 und die Bertelsmann Gesellschaft und daneben noch ganz kleinen Vox. Also das mal die private Senderlandschaft in Deutschland. Wenn Bertelsmann und Kirchen eine Allianz gemacht hätten im Digital-TV, hätte das bedeutet, dass sie im Free-TV keine echten Konkurrenten mehr wären, beziehungsweise sie hätten gemeinsam sagen können, okay wir nehmen jetzt alle interessanten Programme und strahlen die nur noch im Digital-TV aus. Diese Allianz wurde also von Leo Kirch verboten und in dem Moment hat Bertelsmann gesagt, wir machen überhaupt nichts mehr. Wir ziehen uns raus aus dem Digitalen-Pay-TV, ist eher alles Bullshit. Und Leo Kirch hat gesagt, wunderbar, okay, dann mach ich Premiere allein weiter und hat in dem Moment ein Problem. Er schuldet nämlich 1, 2 Milliarden Mark oder sowas um den Dreh. Bertelsmann, die er noch bezahlen muss dafür. Okay, das heißt Kirch hat ein Finanzproblem, das ist bekannt, können wir auch drüber reden, was das ist. Bertelsmann hat natürlich witzig weitergemacht. Die haben einfach angefangen zu sagen, wir machen Internet und haben irgendwie so unter dem Deckmäntelchen des Internets heftig weiterentwickelt an eigenen Broadband-Services, die sie jetzt mit ihrer Broadband-Group irgendwie broadbanden wollen.
Ja gut, wobei Bertelsmann, kann man glaube ich sagen, ja sehr klassische Konzepte hatten. Also die stellen sich digitales Multimedia und das Jahr 2300 dann so vor, dass man eben Pay-per-View letztlich hat.
Ne, ne, ne, die sind, Bertelsmann ist nicht blöd. Also Bertelsmann, die haben den Bertelsmann Buchverlag.
Blöd sind die sicherlich nicht, das habe ich nicht gedacht. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass sie ignorant sind. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die sehenden Auges und sich sehr bewusst der Konzepten aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen.
Dr. Thomas Mittelhoff weiß genau, was er tut. Also Mittelhoff weiß genau, was er tut. Er möchte einfach irgendwie seinen AOL, seine Shopping-Sachen, BOL, Bertelsmann Online, Buch online und CD online und alles mögliche E-Commerce möchte er auf eine Konsumerplattform bringen und möchte es irgendwie den Konsumern breitbandig nach Hause jagen, damit er irgendwie seine Dienste dem Konsument verkauft. Er überlegt sich, wie kann ich mit digitalem Fernsehen Geld machen? Das ist bei PayTV so eine Frage. Weil ich meine, da braucht es Abonnenten, die müssen 30 Mark zahlen. Es gab jetzt gerade eine Umfrage, da hieß es, was sind die Leute bereit dafür zu zahlen für digitales Fernsehen? 50 Mark sind wenige dazu bereit. Die meisten wollen nur etwa 30 Mark zahlen im Monat. Und Mittlehoff sagt einfach, okay, die Leute bekommen irgendwie unsere Channels und sie zahlen für AOL-TV, für Mehrwertdienste, für Shopping-Applikationen. Er kann das durchfinanzieren. Und sie machen Video-on-demand, also über Internet geht natürlich auch. Er nennt das ganze Internet und Leo Kirch nennt das ganze Fernsehen. Wir befinden uns aber in Zeiten der Konvergenz. Und Fernsehen ist Internet. Also vergesst den Begriff Fernseher, vergesst den Begriff Computer. Es gibt ein digitales, visuelles, audiovisuelles Endgerät. Es gibt Netze, Geräte und Dienste.
Na gut, aber ganz wörtlich würde ich dich jetzt ungern nehmen wollen. Weil beim Fernseher, da hab ich irgendwie, da sind 8 Tasten oder so und beim Computer hab ich noch ein paar mehr. Und die Rückkanalmöglichkeit bei einem Fernsehgerät besteht auch nicht so ganz direkt, dass ich jetzt irgendwie der Tagesschau-Redaktion sagen kann, was sie da für komische Prioritäten setzen, wenn sie mir 8 Minuten Sport zumuten und dann noch eine Minute Lotto zahlen und dann nebenbei noch die Katastrophen des Weltgeschehens in den ersten zwei Minuten zusammenfassen. Also insofern ganz vergessen würde ich diese Begriffe ungern. Aber ich denke, wir reden auch mal über die Unterschiede zwischen den Medien und der, und das meinte ich eben mit Ignoranz, dem Grad des Entgegenkommens, der jemand wie Mittelhoff dann auch bereit ist, der auf der einen Seite Geld verdienen will, auf der anderen Seite da ein Medium irgendwie auch nutzt, das sich aus bestimmten Gründen durchsetzt, inwieweit er sich damit arrangieren mag.
Das Wichtige ist, ich mein, es mag vielleicht negativ klingen, aber Mittelhoff macht genau das Richtige. Der Mann hat genau verstanden, worauf es ankommt. Wenn ich er wäre, würde ich genau das Gleiche machen. Was ich interessant finde, ist vielleicht die Frage, wer denn das Rennen macht im digitalen Fernsehen in Deutschland?
Da steht einer nicht auf die Musik, höre ich gerade im Chat.
Das ist uns...
Abschalten.
Relativ egal.
Genau, schalte dein Radio aus.
Das mit der Musik, das klappt sowieso immer nicht. Also irgendeiner ist immer am meckern und das macht überhaupt nichts. DJ Claude, etwas gehandicapt leider technisch, weil er sonst mit drei, vier Soundquellen gleichzeitig arbeitet. Das geht mit unserem Pult hier nicht. Das ist dann so ein relativ normales DJ-Pult, wo halt immer nur zwei Quellen gleichzeitig funktionieren, aber trotzdem sehr Chaos-Radio-like, finde ich. Wir haben ein Chaos Computer Club im Studio, Martin, Christian, Andi und Andreas, und reden über das digitale Fernsehen. Oder wie Martin gerade gesagt hat, Fernsehen, Internet, diese ganzen Begriffe könnt ihr vergessen, denn in Zukunft gibt es schon einen Ausdruck dafür. Nur noch das digitale visuelle Medium oder...
Ich würde das einfach mal das Netz nennen.
Das Netz. Es läuft darauf hinaus, das Netz und die Netzanschlüsse. So, wobei die Netzanschlüsse kann natürlich auch im Extremfall deine Kaffeemaschine sein. Die bauen ja auch schon die ersten Webterminist im Mikrowellenherde ein. Also im Zweifelsfall kannst du dich wahrscheinlich irgendwann auch mit deiner Klobrille über aktuelle Geschehnisse im Netz unterhalten.
Jeden Morgen ein bisschen Urinprobenwerte an. Genau, vielleicht. Der kann dir ja ruf dich dann an, wenn du aus dem Bad kommst. Der sagt dann, Herr Häusler, Ihre Werte gefallen mir gar nicht. Ich glaube, wir müssen uns mal sehen. Ach, es wird toll werden. Ja, super wird's. Ihr seid aber schon mittendrin in der Diskussion.
Ja, ich lass mich gleich unterbrechen. Ich hab ja vorhin gefragt, wer macht das Rennen in Deutschland bei den Fernsehmachern? Und das ist ganz interessant, was momentan stattfindet. Es ist halt eben eine Neuverteilung des Kuchens.
Es gibt...
Es gibt drei Mächte eigentlich. Also zum einen die Battlesmänner, zum anderen die Kirchens. Dann gibt es den Murdoch, der gerade Fett einsteigt in Deutschland und nicht zu vergessen, da sagt nachher der Andi was dazu, die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender, die wir mit unseren Gez-Gebühren bezahlen. Ja, wer macht das Rennen? Das Rennen macht der, der die attraktivsten Inhalte ausstrahlt und die meisten Zuschauer irgendwie vor seine Kanäle zerrt, damit die möglichst viel Werbung gucken und dann gehen die Werbeeinnahmen hoch. Und deswegen werden die Quotenmacher gezeigt. Die Quotenmacher sind SSS, Spielfilm, Sport, Sex und wer am meisten von diesen drei Sachen irgendwie zu den kleinsten Preisen einkauft und die größten Gewinne macht mit der Ausstrahlung, der macht das Rennen im digitalen Fernsehen in Deutschland.
Noch mal ganz kurz, das SSS hieß was bei dir?
Spielfilm, Sport, Sex, das sind so bekanntermaßen die Quotenmacher des Fernsehens.
Da kenne ich nämlich eine andere Definition, wir haben ja vor zwei Jahren mal uns mit der Sicherheit von GSM beschäftigt und blödlicherweise ist uns der eigentliche GSM-Hack an einem Samstag Nachmittag gelungen. Und dann dachten wir halt, na der Spiegel ist jetzt längst im Druck, was ist denn jetzt der nächste Newsflash? Und dann kam mir die Idee Spiegel TV, weil die sind ja sonntag abends und dann habe ich bei Spiegel TV einen Redakteur, den ich anrufe, anrufen und habe ihm das erklärt. Der hat dann mit seiner Redaktion irgendwie Rücksprache erhalten und sagte, es täte ihm schrecklich leid, aber das würde nun mal sonntagabend auf RTL ausgestrahlt und das müsse sich also an einem Niveau orientieren, wo der halb betrunkene RTL-Zuschauer eben irgendwie das gerade noch mitbekommt. Und die Stichworte, die Erda nannte, waren also Blutsperma-Nazis-Drogen. Lässt sich schwerer abkürzen, ne? Ja, ist richtig, aber wie auch immer. Und dann meint er eben, tut mir leid, da ist so ein GSM-Hack Unsicherheit von Mobilfunk, ist einfach sonntagabend schon nicht vermittelbar.
Außer ich wäre einem betrunkenen...
Ja, ja, klar, so funktioniert das dann vom Niveau her, aber darüber reden wir ja heute fast gar nicht.
Inhaltlich zu reden wird wahrscheinlich extrem schwer. Also wenn man dann anfängt mit, wir haben ja eigentlich vorgehabt, in drei Stunden ist natürlich immer wenig Zeit, aber wir haben eigentlich vorgehabt, auch noch irgendwie auf die Geschichte der ganzen Sache einzugehen und da muss man natürlich auch über Sendeaufträge mal reden und bla, öffentlich-rechtlich haben wir eine ganz andere Geschichte. Inhaltlich da auch noch zu diskutieren wird wahrscheinlich extrem schwierig, müsste man auch mal extra machen. Gleich gibt es einen Fritz-Kurz-Info und danach werden wir... Was wollten wir danach machen? Achso, überhaupt mal ein bisschen erklären, wie man mit diesen bewegten Bildern überhaupt Geld verdient.
Wie viele Sekunden habe ich noch für Informationen?
Na, 30.
Also, es gibt keine Kanäle mehr, es gibt Programme. Das ist ein Unterschied im digitalen Fernsehen. Stellt euch vor, im Internet gäbe es Kanäle. Wäre total Bullshit, wenn das Fernsehen das Netz ist, dann gibt es Kanäle nicht mehr, sondern es gibt Programme, die du gucken kannst. Und es ist mir total egal, ob das Programm von RTL oder von Saat1 kommt. Ich habe eine Setterbox, wo ich mich eintune auf Programme und ich sehe überhaupt nicht mehr, wer sie gesendet hat. Das ist ein Problem. Und es ist auch ein Problem, weil kleine Sender, die vielleicht nur einen Channel haben, einen Stream, ein Programm, trotzdem Quote machen können. Und auch vom Equipment her wären sie jetzt möglich, das zu senden. Das heißt, ich stelle einen Computer hin und dann gehe ich ans Netz, ich zahle meinen Provider und dann sende ich. Und das ist es. Und das kann jeder sehen. Vor diesem Hintergrund wird momentan der Kuchen verteilt. Das heißt, momentan versuchen Kirch und Bertelsmann erstmal möglichst viele Frequenzen zu kriegen im Kabel, damit sie möglichst viele Kanäle aussenden können, Programme auf den Kanälen aussenden können und dass die anderen nicht reinkommen, weil sie halt eben keinen Platz im Kabel haben. Das ist bald gelöst, bald gibt es Platz genug für alle im Kabel. Also ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, so ab Mitte nächsten Jahres. Ab da versuchen halt eben Premiere irgendwie und Bertelsmann und alle am Start zu sein.
Aber sollten wir nicht aufhören, die mit Namen zu nennen? Sollten wir nicht einfach die digitalen WG-Lagerer sagen?
Wieso? Die Fernsehmacher in Deutschland, die machen es doch richtig.
Ja gut, aber die sitzen ja auch ein bisschen dann an genau der Stelle, wo sie dann eben Fett abkassieren, wenn da überhaupt jemand erstmal senden will.
Okay, jetzt noch ein Punkt irgendwie. Sie versuchen es natürlich mit fiesen Methoden. Das heißt, sie versuchen irgendwie technische Standards zu schaffen, dass die anderen halt eben nicht können. Und dass halt eben irgendwelche Boxen schon in den Wohnzimmern stehen, die dann die anderen nicht reinkriegen und sowas. Das ist das eine Problem. Und dieses Problem wird gelöst durch die MHP. Das heißt, es gibt mittlerweile europäische Standards, die es allen erlauben, irgendwie reinzukommen und empfangen zu werden. Und Kirch windet und wehrt sich, seine D-Box endlich so umzuarbeiten, eben wie das er es kann. Er hat diese D-Box übrigens schon auf Lage. Er hat sie auch schon gezeigt auf der Funkausstellung. Kirch hat eine MHP-Box und er wird sie genau in den Moment bringen, wo er merkt, alles andere, also Blockade oder so, ist nicht mehr. Dann sagt er, wieso, hab ich doch schon lange.
Was schätzt du, wie viel Zeit das jetzt gerade war, der Infoblock?
Keine Ahnung.
Ah, zwei Minuten.
Aber ganz gut.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Das ist 22.31 Uhr.
Attentat. Der amienische Ministerpräsident Sakesianis ist heute bei einem Anschlag in der Hauptstadt Yerevan erschossen worden. Mit ihm starben mindestens sechs weitere führende Politiker. Mehrere bewaffnete Männer hatten während einer Parlamentstibatte das Feuer auf die Anwesenden eröffnet, genommen zahlreiche Personen als Geiseln. Beschloss die Eskalation nach den bisher schwersten Notangriffen auf der große Költe gehauptert. Russland wolle ein für alle Mal die Zentrale des internationalen Terrorismus in Tschechien zerstören. Angriff, ein serbischer Flüchtlingskonvoi und die NATO-Eskorte sind heute in der Kosovo Stadt Pec von wütenden Albanern gestoppt worden. Mehrere Fahrzeuge wurden in Brand gesteckt. Rund 150 Flüchtlinge waren auf dem Weg nach Montenegro. Doping-Urteil, das DFB-Sportgericht hat die Spielsperre für den Nürnberger Fußballprofeuille Thomas Ziemer auf ein halbes Jahr festgelegt. In erster Instanz war Ziemer zu einer neunmonatigen Sperre verurteilt worden. Er hatte ein verbotenes Muskelaufbaupräparat angenommen. In dieser Nacht bleibt es bei uns meist trocken. Wir werten zwischen 9 und 7 Grad morgen, dann bewölkt teils auch heute bei 12 bis 15 Grad. Berlin-Andenburg weiter eine gute Fahrt.
So weit das Fritz-Kurs-Info mit Matthias Karkow. Gleich gibt's noch Alba.
Sie sind wieder da.
So gut wie lang nicht mehr.
So ist es. Alba spielte in der Europa-Liga heute gegen Panathinaikos Athen und aus der Berliner Max-Schmieling-Halle. Nun Tom Thiermann-Böttcher mit der Schlussreportage.
Es hat nicht sollen sein für Alba Berlin im heutigen Spiel der Europa-Liga-Gruppe gegen den Favoriten aus Athen gegen Panathinaikos Athen. Es hat eine deutliche Niederlage gesetzt, da jetzt noch 34 Sekunden zu spielen sind. Es steht 54 zu 73 und 73 Punkte. Das hat der Favorit. Das haben die Griechen, auch wenn sie jetzt den Ball verlieren. Seit 10 Minuten plätschert das Spiel so mehr oder weniger dahin. Die Luft ist raus. Es werden keine Rebounds auf Berliner Seite mehr geholt. Und die Griechen fahren das Ding ganz ganz locker nach Hause. Sie haben noch keine Saisonniederlage, weder auf nationaler, noch auf internationaler Ebene, bisher auf ihrem Konto. Und das bleibt also auch nach diesem Abend so. In der ersten Halbzeit haben wir uns hier in der Halle sehr, sehr aufgeregt. Wir und die 6000 Zuschauer über einige unerklärliche Schiedsrichter pfiffen. In der zweiten Halbzeit wurde das zwar besser, doch da schien Alba schon völlig nervös und kürr gemacht und konnte nie wieder anschließen an die tolle Leistung von vor einer Woche gegen den amtierenden Europa-Liga-Champion Salgiris Kaunas. Das Trauerspiel hat in diesem Moment ein Ende, 54 zu 73. Eine ganz, ganz saftige Niederlage für Alba Berlin, die man allerdings sehr, sehr schnell abhaken sollte. Denn schon nächste Woche, am Donnerstag der nächsten Woche, kommt mit Tofas Boza eine weitere Klassemannschaft hier nach Berlin. Der türkische Champion, bei dem man auch auswärts verloren hat. Und da zählt es dann wieder. Da muss man diese Niederlage von heute vergessen. Und ich sag euch noch kurz die Punktschützen von diesem Spiel. Der beste Schütze bei Alba Berlin, Frankie King, mit 20 Punkten, gefolgt von Wendel Alexis mit 12 Punkten und Patrick Fehmarnling mit 8 Punkten. Und überragend auf der Seite der Griechen, Vaseko Repratcha mit 13 Punkten, Dejan Bodiroga kommt auf 12 Punkte. Und der Deutsche, der Ex-Lewakusener Mike Koch, hat auch sehr, sehr gut gespielt und hat 3-3 versenkt und kommt damit auf 9 Punkte. Also saftig die Niederlage für Alba Berlin, 54 zu 73 vor 6000 Zuschauern in der Mark-Schmähling-Halle nächste Woche gegen Tofas Bosa am Donnerstagabend hier in Berlin wird's hoffentlich besser.
Das war Tom Thürmann Böttcher und hier geht's weiter mit dem Chaos Radio. Danke für's Zuhören! Wir haben eigentlich beste Chancen heute Einschaltrekorde zu brechen, denn wir haben zwei von drei Essen haben wir schon gehabt. Wir sind eine Serie, weil wir jeden letzten Mittwoch am Monat stattfinden. Sport hatten wir auch gerade.
Was hattest du, Essen?
Ja, die drei Esses. Die drei Esses. Jetzt kann Andi dann ein bisschen Sex in die Sendung bringen und dann haben wir auch Einschaltquoten.
Sackgasse.
Ja und die Drogen?
Das war ein anderer Kanal.
Es geht um das digitale Fernsehen oder das digitale Medium.
Dass man das hier nur hören kann.
Visuelle Medium. Es geht um das Netz und es geht um die Überschrift MP3 für die Augen. Denn die MP3-Diskussion ist für euch sicher schon richtig langweilig geworden, oder?
Langeweile kommt eigentlich später auf. Erstmal erzählt uns Andreas Herzen über Wertschöpfungskritzen.
Vielleicht sollten wir dazu das MP3-Thema gleich nochmal aufrollen. Da ist gerade das Problem, dass die Plattenindustrie, die Tonträgerindustrie darüber klagt, dass ihre Umsätze schwinden und die Gewinne da hinschmelzen. Und sie schieben das auf die bösen CD-Rohlinge und noch viel, viel mehr auf das böse Internet und die bösen MPEGs. Und was da aber eigentlich passiert ist, dass ein Zwischenschritt zwischen dem, der Musik macht und dem, der sich die Musik anhört, jetzt wegfällt, weil er nicht mehr gebraucht wird durch die Technologie MP3. Und so eine ähnliche Situation werden wir bei den Filmen auch bekommen. Weil Filme kann man auch kopieren, sind auch digitale Daten. Da sind noch ein bisschen größere Mengen, als MP3 momentan ist. Aber das wird alles in kürzester Zeit händelbar. Also ich denke mal in ein bis zwei Jahren. Das bemerkenswerte am digitalen Fernsehen und ebenso bei den DVDs, ist ja, dass es sich dabei auch um MPEG handelt. Und zwar in dem Fall MPEG 2 Videoströme, die man ganz genauso gut aufzeichnen, kopieren, brennen und so weiter und so fort kann. Und da wird sich so eine ähnliche Situation ergeben, wie sie sich auch schon bei den MP3s bei der Plattenindustrie gegeben hat. Nämlich die viele Zwischenschritte, die dazwischen geschaltet sind, die fallen weg. Und beim Film ist es so, dass die Anzahl der Zwischenschritte doch relativ groß ist. Also es läuft dann so, da wird in Hollywood ein Film gedreht, wird viel Geld für ausgegeben, dann wird das erst mal alles in Marketing gesteckt. Dann, das kostet, aber dann gehen die einnahmenlos, dann läuft der Film in den Kinos an, dann gibt es Merchandising, dann kommt der Film in die Kinos nach Europa, dann gibt es Merchandising in Europa, dann kommt der Film in Amerika auf Video raus, manchmal sogar bevor er im Kino in Europa rauskommt, dann kommt er in Europa auf Video raus, dann kommt er ins Pay-TV in Ameland, dann kommt er in Deutschland ins Pay-TV, dann kommt er zu den Privaten und dann irgendwann mal vielleicht auch bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, nachts um 11 Uhr.
Videothek hast du schon?
Ja genau, dann kommen die Videos in die Videotheken und irgendwo dazwischen kommen auch noch die DVDs, nachdem wir sich das die Leute vorstellen, und das fällt halt einfach alles weg.
Wer von euch hat einen DVD-Player?
Wir. Jedenfalls, am Schluss haben ihn alle gesehen. Das ist das, was...
Vor allem haben alle bezahlt.
Am Schluss haben alle bezahlt, den Film zu sehen. Jeder Einzelnen und ja manche mehrfach, wenn sie ihn mehrfach gesehen haben. Das Szenario, was jetzt passieren kann, ist, dass ich beispielsweise aus Amiland eine DVD geschickt krieg von einem Freund, guck mir den Film an und denk mir, hm, geiler Film, lohnt sich das nochmal, den Film im Kino anzusehen? Nee, lohnt sich eigentlich nicht. Wenn ich die DVD jetzt irgendwie kopiere und noch einem Freund von mir gebe, dann geht das dem ebenso. Auf Deutsch gesagt, wenn einmal ein Film rauskommt und digitalisiert wird und verteilt wird, dann ist die Wertschöpfungskette empfindlich gestört. Das heißt, im Extremfall weiß der Film, so wie Star Wars 1, wir hatten ihn eine Woche, glaube ich, nachdem er in Amieland gezeigt wurde. Wem ging das, Andi? Erzähl mal.
War das diese Aufnahme aus einem japanischen Kino, aus der letzten Reihe, mit einem...
Die war super.
Das ging übrigens schneller. Nach dem Donnerstag war das, nach der Premiere.
Ja, das war relativ plötzlich. Eigentlich noch am selben Tag, vielleicht einen Tag später. Bis das dann überall durchgetröpfelt ist, hat das ungefähr eine Woche gedauert. Dann hat das wirklich jeder auf der Platte gehabt.
In Köln hat ein Freund von einem kleinen Cousin von mir irgendwie eine Woche lang ein Download gemacht. Der geht noch zur Schule, der ist zwölf.
Das Wichtigste ist, er zahlt die Telefonrechnung nicht selber.
Nee, seine ist eine echte.
Das war teuer. Jedenfalls war das so, dass dieser Film dann vorlag und wo er schon mal da war und sowieso erst mal in den nächsten drei Monaten nicht ins Kino kommen, konnte man sich dann ja auch mal angucken. Dann stellt man fest, dass er irgendwie doch nicht so prall ist, wie der Hype verspricht. Und dass man ihn dann vielleicht doch lieber nicht im Kino angucken will oder so. Und das kostet die halt echt Geld.
Ich hab in der Video-CD gesehen, es reicht mehr.
Im Falle von Star Wars hatte das bestimmt noch keine kommerziellen Auswirkungen. Das ist aber leicht abzusehen, wann es das haben wird.
Im Gegenteil. Also ich meine bei denen war es ja sogar so, dass die teilweise in Vorab digitalisierte Sequenzen rausgegeben haben. So ähnlich wie auch Künstler im Internet ihre Musik als MP reinstellen. Und genau wissen die Leute, wollen dann doch die CD irgendwie haben. Und man kann das ja auch als Geschäftsmodell betrachten, sozusagen, um einfach nur Qualität durchzusetzen. Und weil damit haben auch kleine Künstler eben die Möglichkeit den Kram reinzustellen. Aber die Musikindustrie und auch die Filmindustrie denke ich, die sehen das ein bisschen verspannter.
Filme werden demnächst gehandelt wie Raubkopien.
Ja, die werden. Wobei Raubkopien ist ja auch so ein Begriff. Fangen wir mal damit an. Was ist denn überhaupt geraubt? Also der Begriff Raubkopie, der ist schon ein Propagandabegriff.
Wenn du an deinem D-Bus ein Kassi-Kabel anschließt und es irgendwie dir auf Platte spielst, was ohne Weiteres möglich ist, dann hast du eine Raubkopie angefertigt.
Ja gut, dann hab ich. Aber im Grunde genommen ist da ja nichts geraubt, sondern da ist etwas verdoppelt. Verdoppelt sind da Daten. Was da geraubt ist, ist etwas ganz virtuelles, nämlich eine Lizenzgebühr, die ich theoretisch hätte zu zahlen, die ich mir vielleicht gar nicht leisten kann.
Du sprichst von Film und Musik so, als ob es Software wäre. Das ist doch auch. Sagen aber die nicht.
Was sagen die denn?
Das ist geistiges Eigentum.
Geistiges Eigentum, genau. Und dann Diebstahl und Schutz geistigen Eigentum.
Es ist geistiges Eigentum. Es ist ein riesen Problem. Es ist nicht geklärt.
Aber gibt es sowas? Wenn ich einen Gedanken habe und nehme mal an, irgendeiner von diesen Zuhörern hier glaubt an kollektives Unterbewusstsein, Gott, Buddha oder was auch immer, dann könnte ich ja auch sagen, wenn ich einen Gedanken habe und den ausspreche oder eine geistige Idee habe, dann ist die sowieso nur ein Output des kollektiven Unterbewusstseins, gehört insofern sowieso allen. Und wenn ich dann hinstelle und ich sage, aber dieser Gedanke ist meiner und den Patentier ich jetzt.
Du erwärst gerade ein Gesellschaftssystem, was nicht mit dem kompatibel ist.
Das hat nicht viel mit der Industrie und dem Gesellschaftssystem zu tun.
Ich hab gerade über religiöne geredet.
Das aus dem kollektiven Unterbewusstsein jeder was anderes macht. Und da wird es dann halt spannend, weil vielleicht einige Leute genau das sehen wollen, was der bestimmte Regisseur daraus macht. Und es geht ja nicht um deine Gedanken. Das geht einfach darum, wenn jetzt irgendjemand diese Sendung tapet und damit woanders die auf RTL ausstrahlt und damit Millionär wird, dann würdest du da auch ein Problem mit haben.
Was ich sage ist GPL.
Ich hätte damit kein Problem.
Jemand anders mit deiner Arbeit Geld verdient?
Also, ich meine, es geht doch hier bei dieser Sendung, es geht uns darum, dass uns Gedanken vollkommen. Und uns kann das doch nur lieb sein, wenn das auf welchen Wegen auch immer möglich ist.
Nee, auf welchen Wegen auch immer nicht. Darum geht es nicht. Wenn jemand das sonst macht, dann habe ich damit kein Problem.
Wenn die Leute bereit sind, den Preis zu zahlen, ich meine, da kann ja jemand anders kommen, kann das auch kopieren und billiger anbieten.
Aber Johnny, da muss jetzt aber keine Reich mit. Du musst aber mal ganz kurz die Motivation unterscheiden. Ich könnte mich jetzt hier hinstellen und könnte sagen, ich bin jetzt irgendwie Künstler und ich will jetzt daran verdienen, dass hier Leute meine Kunst irgendwie rezipieren. Ich kann aber auch sagen, ich bin irgendwie Schnittstelle des kollektiven Unterbewusstseins zum kollektiven Überbewusstseins. Und als solchen möchte ich möglichst viel von unten nach oben schaufeln. Und auf welchem Wege das da ankommt, ist mir auch egal.
Das ist dir aber ab einem bestimmten Punkt nicht mehr egal. Also ich finde diese Copyright-Diskussion ist wirklich eine ganz, ganz schwierige Wahl.
Kann ich mal kurz unterbrechen für eine kleine Ansage. Und zwar hören wir jetzt den ORB Radio-EPG. Das ist ein Electronic Program Guide für das Fernsehen, exklusiv im Radio. Also ihr könnt jetzt interaktiv durch das Hören dieser Radiosendung zu eurem Fernseher gehen und dort die ARD einschalten, weil da kommt in einer Viertelstunde ein guter Film von Wong Kar Wai. Den Titel habe ich schon wieder vergessen, aber ich habe den im Kino gesehen.
Schade, dass du den Titel nicht wenigstens hast.
Guck doch mal nach Andreas, wir haben doch hier Internet.
Da ist irgendwie kein Zeitpunkt um 23 Uhr eine ARD oder dieses Ding braucht nicht.
Es gibt hier Telefon, kann man jemand anrufen und durchsagen.
Ja, mach mal Internet. Aber darüber reden wir hier gar nicht.
Radio.
Nee, schon über die wichtige Frage. Also ich bin in dieser Copyright-Diskussion so ein bisschen gespalten, weil auf der einen Seite ich weiß, was du meinst und finde, du hast auch recht, aber ich habe ein extremes Problem damit. Hab ja selber mal Musik gemacht und ich wollte zum Beispiel nicht unbedingt, dass, weiß ich nicht, die Bundeswehr plötzlich in ihren Fernsehspots meinen Song benutzen darf.
Ja, das kannst du ihnen auch verbieten. Das Copyright wird dadurch nicht gebrochen, dass irgendetwas frei kopiert wird. Das Copyright hast du immer. Du hast die Rechte an deinem Werk.
Da bin ich deiner Meinung. Aber ich finde, man muss da Unterscheidungen treffen, und zwar kommerzielle, nicht kommerzielle Nutzung und so weiter.
Die Filmindustrie hat die Rechte an dem Werk. Das heißt, nicht der Regisseur, nicht der Autor, nicht das Team hat die Rechte, sondern das Studio, das die Produktion finanziert. Die haben die Rechte, die haben sozusagen das Copyright. Und die sagen, nein, das Ding darf nicht kopiert werden. Dann schicken sie es raus, und in dem Moment, wo sie es rausschicken...
Fallen Angels heißt der Film, fandst du den gut? Danke.
Zu so einem EPG gehört jetzt noch Regisseur und wer mitspielt.
Kann man dann auf Hyperlinks bei dir klicken?
Muss man dann auch alle paar Minuten eine Münze hinter sein Fernseher werfen?
Ja Leute, ich gebe euch jetzt meine Kontonummer durch, und ihr müsst dann jeder eine Mark überweisen.
18 völlig reichen.
Okay, weiter. Das mit den Rechten, genau. Also es ist tatsächlich eine Copyright-Verletzung, wenn frei herumkopiert wird, und das ist ein riesen Problem, und das ist auch illegal. Das muss man wirklich sagen, es ist illegal, wenn ihr euch eine Kopie macht von einer DVD, aber es ist technisch möglich. Und das ist genau das gleiche, wie wenn ihr irgendwie Microsoft Word gekauft habt.
Also es ist ungefähr so, als würdet ihr ohne zu zahlen in der S-Bahn fahren.
In der S-Bahn nehme ich jemanden einen Platz weg.
Es ist ja so, wenn ich eine Software kopiere.
Wenn ich eine Software kopiere oder wenn ich ein Film kopiere.
Raubkopieren ist illegal. WAS, das ist was für die WAS-Szene. Hier ist der Chaos Computer Club.
Aber Copyright ist doch Aberglaube.
Martin, ich würde jetzt ganz kurz mal eine Sache vielleicht klarstellen, warum ich mit dem Begriff Raubkopieren einfach ein echtes Problem habe. Es gibt ja eine novellierte, wie es heißt, europäische einheitliche Urheberrechtsgesetzgebung. Und nach der ist ein urheberrechtlicher Verstoß. Also wenn ihr euch also eine Raubkopie einer Software, eines Liedes, eines Videos, was auch immer eben anlegt, das ist jetzt ein Strafrechtsdelikt. Das heißt nicht wie früher, da war das Zivilrecht, da musste dann derjenige, der das Recht hatte, musste dann eine Anzahl stellen und musste sagen, er hat mir virtuell 500 Mark genommen, weil er hat nicht gezahlt. Und jetzt ist es aber so, dass die Polizei eben theoretisch muss. Das heißt, wenn die euch in die Hütte ausräumen wegen was auch immer und dabei einen Computer finden mit offensichtlich nicht bezahlter Software, dann muss die Polizei einschreiten. Und der Trick ist eben der, dass andersherum könnte man auch sagen, also ein Großteil der Computerbesitzer ist einfach ein Straftäter. Und das hat natürlich auch Auswirkungen auf das Verhältnis der Bürger zum Staat. Wenn nämlich das total egal ist, weil wir sowieso alle illegal sind, weil wir alle Software drauf haben, die wir mal ausprobieren wollen, bevor wir sie kaufen, so, dann können wir auch gleich...
Es bedeutet einfach, es macht den Leuten nichts aus und sie machen es trotzdem.
Und die Frage ist ja, insofern, jetzt mal ganz kurz zu den Wertschöpfungsketten der Filmindustrie, gibt es denn eine Alternative? Wenn wir sagen, wir brauchen den Verleih nicht, und wir würden ja, wenn Stanley Kubrick einen coolen Film macht, dann wollen wir gerne aus seiner Witwe die Markt zukommen.
Lass mal Andreas das alternative Modell vorstellen.
Ja, also das alternative Modell basiert auf der einfachen Überlegung, dass es ja auch Geld kostet, Kopien zu vertreiben. Also wenn ich jetzt einen Server aufsetze, wo ich eine Menge mp3s und auch noch ein paar Video-CDs drauf habe, Star Wars, dann kostet mich das ja Geld. Weil ich für den Traffic bezahle, weil ich für die Maschine bezahle, weil ich für den Plattenplatz bezahle und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, wenn es legal wäre, das zu kopieren, dann würden die Leute das trotzdem nicht machen, würde nicht jeder hingehen und irgendwie große Server aufstellen, weil das Geld kostet. Also muss das irgendwie kompensiert werden. Und die Kosten für die Verteilung, die tatsächlichen Kosten, sind natürlich deutlich niedriger als das, was man jetzt momentan irgendwie an der Kinokasse für eine CD und so weiter und so fort bezahlt.
Aber dafür musst du den Stuhl, auf dem du bequem sitzt, ja auch selber kaufen dann.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber das ist im Zusammenhang nicht zur Sache, weil in dem Moment, wo ich sowieso ein bisschen was bezahlen muss, zwei oder drei Mark, ist es kein Problem auch noch eine Mark an den Künstler, den irgendwie Urheber oder einen Rights Owner abzuführen. Das heißt, alles was da passiert ist, dass dieser ganze Overhead mit den Filmverleis und den Produktionsstudios und den Kinobesitzern und den...
Ja, die Zwischenhändler, dieses Zwischenhändler-Markler-Gesatzfeld.
Markler, genau.
Das Packler.
Die fallen einfach weg. Sondern wenn du zum Beispiel eine CD machst und suchst die CD aufs Internet, sind 50 Megabyte, kostet dich irgendwie ein Server Traffic 5 Mark, ungefähr wenn es jemand downloadet, vielleicht auch nur zwei. Dann gibt er locker nochmal 2 Mark aus. Dann hat man seine CD 2 Mark verdient. Der Kunde hat 5 bezahlt. Und beide Seiten sind glücklich.
Dann machen wir uns doch nichts vor. Wir betreiben gerade die massive Freistellung von Arbeitskräften am Markt. Man nennt das auch Produktion von Arbeitslosigkeit. Und ich glaube wir haben einen Heidenspaß dabei.
MP3 für die Augen, das ist die Überschrift heute im Chaosradio. Computerblumen, wir erzählen jetzt Nimmermord auf der von euch gelegten Frequenz. Chaos Computer Club ist im Studio, DJ Claude legt auf und Johnny ist noch am Mikrofon und versucht mitzubekommen, worüber hier geredet wird Martin, Christian, Andi und Andreas vom CCC. Sie sind hier und wir haben viele Begriffe schon durcheinander auf den Set-Drop-Boxen. Die Kursgruppe, die Battlesmänner und was haben wir noch vergessen?
Die Set-Drop-Kisten.
Die Set-Drop-Kisten sind schon ziemlich viele wichtige Namen gefallen. Wir werden demnächst die Telefonleitung hier öffnen für euch. Unsere Telefonnummer bei Fritz solltet ihr kennen. Die lautet nämlich folgendermaßen.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Und zuallererst wollen wir heute Abend von euch wissen, wer von euch denn schon in die digitale Filmwelt vorgedrungen ist. Das heißt, wir wollen erstmal mit Leuten reden, die entweder schon einen DVD-Player gekauft haben und den wahrscheinlich dann auch benutzen mit den fünf Filmen, die es gibt. Obwohl es gibt schon ein paar. Wir wollen von euch wissen, wer sich Video-CDs zum Beispiel aus Internet-Dateien runterlädt. Wir wollen von euch wissen, wer in einer Set-Top-Box bei sich zu Hause stehen hat und so weiter und so fort. Also wer von euch ist schon in die digitale Filmwelt vorgedrungen?
Und wer von denjenigen hat überhaupt Gewissensbisse oder nicht? Oder antrechts-
Und vor allen Dingen möchte ich gerne wissen, was ihr beruflich macht, wo ihr die Zeit hernimmt, noch so viel Fernsehen zu gucken. Telefon 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110 und wir erzählen euch dann, bis die ersten Anrufer durch sind, ein paar lustige Geschichten, Anekdoten aus der Welt, sehr bunten Bilder.
Eine Anmerkung wollte ich machen zu, du sagtest gerade Zeit, versuche hier Fernsehen gucken. Das Bemerkenswerte an dem digitalen Fernsehen ist eigentlich nicht nur, dass es plötzlich viel mehr Angebot gibt, sondern dass man auch viel weniger davon guckt, weil man eigentlich sowieso von dem, was kommt, überfordert ist. Wenn man einfach nur so reinsetzt, wird man vom Angebot erschlagen. Es ist grundsätzlich langweilig. Das heißt, man sucht sich genau aus, was man gucken will. Das führt dazu, dass man nicht mehr besonders viel guckt.
Und vor allem nicht mehr die Scheiße, die die ganze Zeit gezeigt wird.
Genau. Ich beobachte das bei mir, dass ich sehr, sehr wenig Fernsehen gucke. So kann ich mich erinnern.
Ich beobachte bei mir, dass ich nur noch zwei Kanäle gucke. Hauptsächlich. Also Ausnahme ist die Harald-Mitschow, aber...
Ich würde das gern vor uns Angels gucken.
Den hast du aber schon im Kino gesehen.
Ja, trotzdem. Der Film ist so gut, kann man zweimal reingehen.
Ich gucke eigentlich mit Vorliebe einen Film des Computer Clubs der Haustar Jungtalente, der DDR, glaube ich. Die haben mal 20 Minuten lang Fernsehgeräte aus dem vierten Stock geworfen.
Das war früher übrigens ganz verbreitet, auch in Westdeutschland. Also es gab so in den 60er Jahren wirklich eine Welle. Immer wenn die Sendungen zu schlecht waren auf den zwei Kanälen, die es gab, haben die Leute wirklich aus Protest-Fernsehgeräten auf die Straße geworfen, haben mir meine Eltern erzählt.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie erste-Mai-Demos im Kreuzpark.
Ich finde das gut, das sollte man wieder einführen, mit Computern, mit Microsoft-Computern.
Aber apropos Fernsehen, wir wollten noch ganz kurz über das öffentliche rechtliche Fernsehen reden.
Leiter sind wir uns auch schon voll, falls sie das mal erzählen wollen.
Das ging aber schnell, vielleicht.
Was wolltest du sagen?
Na, wir wollten ganz kurz über die öffentlich-rechtlichen reden. Die ja theoretisch mal einen Bildungsauftrag hatten. Und früher gab es ja dieses Gesellschaftsmodell, dass der Staat dann auch über sowas wie öffentliches rechtliches Fernsehen seinen Informationspflichten und so weiter und fortgerecht wird. Das hat sich ja nun ein bisschen geändert. Die sind jetzt genauso voller Werbung, auch wenn sie es vielleicht auch gar nicht müssten. Die AD hat, wie man gerade hört, einen 3-Stelle-Millionen-Betrag-Überschuss ausversehen, der wirtschaftet, weil sie irgendwie doch dachten, sich so verhalten zu müssen wie RTL. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Die haben natürlich diese digitale Entwicklung auch gesehen. Haben gesehen, dass was Kirch da macht, das wäre irgendwie von der letzten Konsequenz hieße, dass sie sind einfach überhaupt nicht mehr empfangen war. Und haben deswegen halt, ja und auch nicht mehr benötigt, genau, die würden dann einfach den Markt unter sich aufteilen und haben ein bisschen versucht, dagegen zu steuern. Versucht ist glaube ich deswegen der richtige Begriff, weil sie zwar mit erheblicher Motivation und auch mit einer Mark-50 da reingegangen sind, aber eben auch erst zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo der Kirch eigentlich schon seiner Boxen, die standen da schon bei den Leuten. So und jetzt gibt es ein Konsortium, was also zwischen Endgeräteherstellern auf der einen Seite, öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender auf der anderen Seite gegründet wurde, das eben FAN heißt. Die haben wiederum einen eigenen Standard entwickelt. Genau, Free Universe Network, so heißt das Ganze. Und wollen also letztendlich eine D-Box bzw. eine Set-Top-Box rausbringen, die eben dann...
Eine Alternative zur D-Box, also es soll eine Box sein, irgendwie eine offene digitale Plattform, auf der natürlich irgendwie Kirch auch senden kann. Aber sie wollen es halt eben verhindern, dass Leo Kirch irgendwie mit seinem Technikmonopol irgendwie das Ganze lockiert.
Kann ich da mal was ganz kurz zwischenfragen? Also ich verstehe nicht ganz wo diese diese diese proprietäre Anwendung der D-Box, das verstehe ich schon. Kirch sagt irgendwie, ich bringe die erste Box auf den Markt. Wenn erstmal alle Leute dafür bezahlt haben und abonniert haben, dann kann ich entscheiden, was darauf gesendet wird. Ist schon klar, aber ich meine der Gedanke hinter fun ist ja offensichtlich, wir sind mehr und wenn wir uns zusammentun und einen offenen Standard schaffen, dann schmeißen die Leute ihre Kirch D-Box weg und kaufen unsere oder bieten unsere.
Genau das ist jetzt die spannende Frage, weil die haben sich nämlich auch ja mit dem Problem beschäftigen müssen, dass sie jetzt erst mal ihre Boxen irgendwie markt kriegen müssen. Da gab es eben ein kleines Projekt, das Projekt hieß Operation.
Nein, nein, das ist was anderes. Also sie haben auf der IFA ihre Boxen vorgestellt irgendwie und das Lustige ist, da ist eine Technik drin, die ist absolut nicht offen. Die nennt sich OpenTV, ist in Frankreich schon ganz verbreitet, irgendwie Kanal Plus arbeitet mit OpenTV und OpenTV ist das ziemlich offensste, was es gibt, also trotzdem ist irgendwie so offen heißt und fun hat sich halt eben so ein bisschen geklüngelt. OpenTV ist auch Gesellschaft, ein Mitglied bei fun und man dachte okay also das war jetzt eben eine schöne Plattform irgendwie für OpenTV und da können sie Marktanteile gewinnen. Ist ganz cool, klingt nicht so besonders offen, gefällt uns auch nicht, also es geht so weiter und ich meine das ist eine ganz interessante Operation. Das wolltest du erklären?
Die Operation Banane, die heißt so und die ist wahrscheinlich auch unter dem Maßstab gemacht, also die ist halt nicht ganz gerade, sondern die ist etwas krumm. Die Idee war eben über die dann doch noch von den Bundesbürgern wahrgenommenen öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehprogramme sozusagen den Absatzmarkt zu schaffen, sprich die wollten über Satellit einfach mal alle öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender in ihren Digitalkanal rein werfen und die privaten natürlich auch, aber eben auch die, die nichts mit Kirch zu tun haben und dann eben sagen so, ihr lieben Bundesbürger und wenn ihr jetzt öffentlich-rechtlichen wollt, er ja in toller digitaler Qualität gucken und dann eben über diese Option einfach jedem so eine Box verkaufen, also im Sinne von jedem und nicht nur jedem, der irgendwie Millionen dafür bezahlt, sondern erstmal wahrscheinlich, denke ich, mehr so Subventionsgeschäfte. Also auch bei der D-Box ist es ja so, die kostet theoretisch Herstellerpreis, glaube ich, so ein Tausender oder 900 irgendwas und man kriegt sie halt mit einem Abo zusammen. Ähnlich wie bei Moduletelefonen läuft da eben diese, wie sagt man, Subventionierung, dass man sich eben verpflichtet, 800 Millionen Jahre irgendwie in Kirchtv zu gucken und dann kostet die Box halt nur noch 50.
Das interessante an dieser Operation Banane war eigentlich, dass das nicht Fun selbst war, sondern das war eine Undercover-Aktion von Fun-Mitgliedern, unter anderem der Vorsitzende, glaube ich, und noch so ein paar Leute. Da ging Dokument rum und wir machen das. Und das sah irgendwie auch so aus, als ob da irgendwie ein bisschen was in Taschen gelenkt werden sollte. Also das ist auch nicht besonders offen.
Ja, ich meine, es ist ja auch nicht ganz uninteressant, jedem Bundesbürger erst mal so eine Kiste zu verkaufen, oder?
Ja klar, du kannst schon irgendwie Geschäfte machen. Also ich meine, wenn du Politik auf deiner Seite hast, hast du eigentlich kein Problem. Ich meine, ich sehe gerade irgendwie der Besuch von Stoiber jetzt in Hollywood irgendwie, um da nochmal Herrn Murdoch zu treffen, dass Herr Murdoch auch wirklich bei Kirch einsteigt, irgendwie mit 25 Prozent und Bayern ist toll. Und da wird jetzt, glaube ich, irgendwie auch Isar Valley gebaut, irgendwie so das Multimedia-Dorf als Alternative zu den Projekten von Wolfgang Clement in NRW, weil Medienstandort Bayern und so.
Deutschland, Deutschland, Stoiber als nächster Bundeskanzler?
Aber wir können ja mal ein paar Hörer jetzt reinnehmen, die haben wir ja auch gefragt, ob sie denn schon überhaupt Erfahrungen damit haben und welche.
Chaosradio hier bei Fritz. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist da?
Der kann nicht telefonieren.
Mach ich irgendwas falsch? Nee, ne? Warte mal. Das blinkt, das ist an. Guck mal.
Lieber Hörer, du musst das mit den Tasten... Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hört ihr mich?
Ja, ich höre mich doppelt.
Ja, das liegt an deinem Radio. Und jetzt hörst du sie gar nicht mehr. So schnell kann das gehen.
Hallo.
Jo, ich hab leider noch kein digitales Fernsehen und auch kein DVD-Player.
Warum sagst du leider?
Ja, ich will es mir demnächst zulegen.
Warum?
Also, digitales Fernsehen zwar nicht, aber ich überlege, ob ich mir einen DVD-ROM für meinen Computer hole.
Weil ich sowieso alles lieber mit dem Computer mache.
Und wenn du dann irgendwie Filme gucken möchtest, wie kommst du an die DVDs? Die sind doch teuer.
Ja, die sind noch teuer. Ich hab vor, die mir eigentlich erst mal aus der Videothek auszuleihen. Die ist ja bei meiner Videothek schon ziemlich günstig, so viel Videopreis. Aber ich weiß noch nicht genau, ob mein Computer wirklich die Videos dann...
Windows, ja?
Jaja, ich hab noch Windows, ich will auch noch Linux auf meinem 2-Computer jetzt demnächst.
Nee, also das wird alles ruckelfrei funktionieren.
Also ich hab auch nicht vor mir eine Decoder-Card zu. Also ich wollte jetzt einfach nur so...
Ja, brauchst du einen schnellen Rechner. Ja, ja. Was ich dich fragen würde gerne wäre, wenn jetzt irgendwie ein Kumpel von dir käme, meinst du irgendeine Schule oder was weiß ich, und würde sagen, hey, willst du einen DVD gucken und willst du die dann leihen von dem? Ja, logisch, und wenn die irgendwie raubkopiert wäre, also eine Scheibe halt eben, wo da nicht das Original-Label drauf wäre?
Ähm, nee, kein Problem.
Kein Problem, ja.
Also es gibt ja auch schon Programme so, mit denen man DVDs sich auf Festival grabben kann. Echt? Ja, so weiß ich jetzt nicht, DVD-Rip oder so?
Von wie viel MB reden wir da?
Ich weiß es nicht genau, weil ich schätze mal, es werden so 5 GB sein oder es ist wahrscheinlich verschieden so.
Bitte? Zwischen 4 und 9 GB sind ein Film.
Gibt es schon anständige DVD-Brenner?
Ja, es gibt DVD-Brenner, aber ich glaube, soweit ich weiß, sind die nicht kompatibel zu den DVD-Playern, die man sich sonst so in, also die halt für den Fernseher.
Es gibt die erschwinglichen DVD-RW-Laufwerke und es gibt die im Moment noch sehr teuren, so um die 11.000 Mark teuren DVD-R-Brenner, die dann auch mit den DVD-Videos kompatibel sind.
Also auch im Fernseher die normalen DVD-Player?
Ja, genau. Da kannst du fast wirklich eine 1 zu 1 Kopie machen.
Und wie lange dauert das noch, bis die dann auch erschwinglich sind, was auch immer das heißt?
Die ersten CD-ROM-Brenner haben auch 10.000 Mark gekostet. Also wir wissen ja, was sie jetzt kosten.
Diese Brenner sind jetzt gerade von 30.000 Mark auf 11.000 Mark runtergegangen. Im Laufe des letzten halben Jahres.
Da bekostet man in einem Jahr einen Tausender.
Genau.
Handy ist aus.
Was mich noch interessieren würde, wäre, wie man am besten DVDs zum Beispiel selber produzieren könnte.
Wenn du einen Film drehst oder?
Ja genau, also erstmal, ich meine, man sollte, man bräuchte ja am besten eine digitale Kamera.
Ja, du kannst das auch irgendwie aus dem Fernsehen aufnehmen. Also wenn du Digital-TV hast.
Ja, also gibt es denn schon digitale Fernsehkarten?
Ja, so was gibt es alles. Also wenn du irgendwie komplett von Anfang an selbst produzieren willst, dann ist es am besten, sich Digital-Kameras zu holen, mit Firewire-Schnittstelle, passende Schnittsoftware dazu. Also so, keine Ahnung, Adobe Premiere ist glaube ich der Marktführer, aber Adobe ist so ein bisschen wie Microsoft. Aber nicht ganz so schlimm. Ja, genau. Also es gibt also eine Handvoll Programme, mit denen kann man das schneiden. Und im Prinzip, deine DVD draus zu machen, die du auch in einen normalen DVD-Player legen kannst, geht momentan mit Hausmitteln nicht. Da braucht man sehr spezielle Software für, DVD-Othering-Software. Die gibt es noch nicht im brauchbaren Preissegment und sowas hat auch selten jemand. Das sind dann meistens so handinstallierte Versionen und die kennen ihre Kunden sehr genau und ohne Hotline kommt man sowieso nicht weiter.
Also, ich hab schon mal eine VCD hergestellt.
Das ist relativ einfach, ja.
Die lässt sich am DVD-Player auch lesen. Hat natürlich eine wesentlich schlechtere Qualität, aber...
Ja, geht auch schon.
Geht schon. Also das ist aber noch nicht erschwinglich so mit DVD und so.
Jan, hast du denn Ambition, selber Filme zu drehen?
Also...
Dokumentation, was auch immer?
Ja, drehen vielleicht nicht so direkt, aber auf jeden Fall die Produktion, also das Digitalisieren und so weiter, würde mich schon interessieren.
Also, weil ich finde das eine enorm spannende Frage. Wir haben ja alle mal gehofft, oder wir nicht, aber viele Leute haben ja behauptet, dass mit dem Durchbruch der Videokamera generell, also der bezahlbaren Videokamera, dass plötzlich die ganzen jungen Regisseure auf den Markt stürmen werden und endlich kann jeder zu Hause seine ganzen wilden Ideen, die er bisher nicht veröffentlichen konnte.
Wie bist du jetzt so von den 70er Jahren, als sie so mit Medienläden angefangen haben?
Ja, als man so gesagt hat, endlich wird das ganze kreative Potenzial in der Bevölkerung den Markt überschwemmen.
Naja, das ist nicht wirklich richtig.
Na ja, warte doch mal. Ich mein, was gefehlt hat, war einfach irgendwie, dass es jemanden zeigen konnten. Jetzt, da es das Netz gibt, können die Leute irgendwie zeigen, was sie da zu Hause so in ihrem Wohn- oder Schlafzimmer oder auf dem Klo gedreht haben.
Da hast du dann auch wahrscheinlich schon zumindest mit den letzten beiden Begriffen... Genau, mit den letzten beiden Begriffen hast du dann das dritte Ess in die Sendung gebracht und wahrscheinlich auch den Kern der Sache getroffen, wofür Videokameras genügt werden.
Ja, ich hatte dann... Hallo? Ich hab dann noch zwei andere Fragen. Und zwar erstens, wie würdet ihr dann die Idee finden, die Chaos Computer Club Sendung von Fritz vielleicht als MP3... auf CD zu brennen und dann vielleicht ab und zu rauszugeben?
Ja, auf CD brennen und rausgeben ist halt immer so viel Arbeit.
Nee, das ist kein Copyright-Problem, das ist ein, wie heißt diese komische Firma, GEMA oder was?
GEMA.
Was mit der Musik ist da ein Problem? Also es gibt sowas, so mitunter taucht sowas mal auf.
Wir machen die Musik hier selbst. Kloh steht momentan am Xylophone.
Ja, wir machen die auf, aber letztendlich legt der da auch so runde Apparate auf diese anderen runden Apparate und die wiederum sind gepresst von Firmen, die wiederum Verträge mit der GEMA haben. Und das Problem ist...
Nee, nee, nee, der hat die Töne selbst erzeugt.
Also das GEMA-Problem ist aber nur eins davon. Also das andere ist halt, dass es einfach Aufwand wäre.
Ja, nee, es ist ja nicht so, dass es das nicht gibt.
Aber...
Nein, man kann es halt nicht kommerziell anbieten.
Mails mit den Anfragen, dann bitte an.
Es gibt möglicherweise den nächsten MP3-Livestream, wenn wir das hinkriegen, wir basteln da dran.
Nee, ich meine jetzt nicht ein Livestream, sondern auf CD jetzt halt.
Das kann man sich doch nicht selber machen.
Ach, kann man sich selber machen. Ich meine, wie ist denn die rechtliche Sache, wenn man sich so was selber macht?
Das ist erlaubt. Also für privaten Gebrauch mitschneiden ist eindeutig.
Du kannst ja so in eine Radiosendung mitschneiden.
Also ich meine die Frage ist, bist du Jurist oder bist du irgendwie Mensch? Nein, natürlich. Der Einfachkeit halber würde ich sagen, es gilt dasselbe wie für andere gesetzliche Lagen auch. Es kommt unter anderem darauf an sich nicht erwischen zu lassen.
Ich meine, das wäre vielleicht eher sinnvoll dafür vielleicht zu gebrauchen, dass wenn man zum Beispiel eine Sendung verpasst hat oder so, oder wenn man sich in der Sendung im Nachhinein nochmal anhören will, dass man das dann halt gleich so kriegen kann und nicht alles selber machen muss. Es wäre halt viel bequemer.
Ja, also wie gesagt der CCC arbeitet daran und du kannst damit rechnen, dass das, naja, sagen wir mal, vielleicht demnächst mal.
Vielleicht fdp.ccc.de ist das Stichwort. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir nebenbei nicht auch ab und zu mal so was machen.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Frage. Gibt es dieses Jahr wieder so ein Chaos Computer Club Treffen im Weltmeer?
Ja, zwischen 27. bis 29. Dezember. Also wir sind noch in den Anfängen der inhaltlichen Planung. Da kann ich noch nicht so viel drüber sagen, aber das Gebäude, der Termin und alles steht.
Ich nehme noch ein paar andere Hörer an. Bis denn. Das erste Mal, dass wir sprachlich gegenüber den Amis einen Vorteil haben, weil www.ccc.de spricht sich definitiv leichter als www.ccc.de.
Ist ja auch von einem Deutschsprachigen entwickelt worden, am CERN.
Schweizer, ne?
Schweizer.
Chaos Radio hier, hallo, wer ist denn da? Ich? Ich denk dann immer sofort, ich mach was falsch. Das ist wie mal beim Computer, wenn da was nicht funktioniert, denke ich auch immer. Liegt bestimmt an mir. Ich hab irgendwas falsch. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaos Radio.
Schieß los.
Ja, also ich hab vielleicht über und über die D-Box.
Wie heißt denn du? Wie heißt denn du?
Andi.
Andi, hallo Andi.
Nochmal einer.
Andi, was machst du mit deiner D-Box?
Jo, ich hör Chaos Radio.
Echt?
Du hörst uns gerade über die D-Box?
Ja genau. Geil.
Total, in Reizformalität.
Dann sitzt du möglicherweise gar nicht hier in der Ecke.
Wo denn?
Ähm, zwischen Ulm und Ravensburg.
Na, du bist gut.
Ja, das sollte man vielleicht auch noch erwähnen. Erstmal, dass man nämlich über die D-Box natürlich auch digitaler Radio-Geschichten...
Andy, Satellit oder Kabel?
Kabel.
Erzähl mal, ähm, wie Premiere World ist. Kannst du jetzt empfangen, ne?
Ja, genau, seit einem Monat.
Und, ist alles anders, ist alles neu?
Ja gut, ich hab vorhin das Premiere Digital gehabt. Und ich hab auf jeden Fall jetzt mal mehr Kanäle. Also Programme.
Und, lohnt sich's? Sollen die Leute sich das kaufen? Mach mal Werbung.
Auf jeden Fall mehr als vorher, sagen wir's mal so.
Okay, und glaubst du, das setzt dich durch, irgendwie, die D-Box? Oder glaubst du irgendwie, dass du die wegschmeißen kannst, nächstes Jahr?
Also die Technik ist schon ein bisschen veraltet, würde ich mal behaupten.
Aha, wieso?
Gut, also ein paar Absturzsicherungen.
Was hast du für eine Software? Beta Nova? Wieso nicht Overflow? Du bist kein Bastler. Du wolltest, glaub ich, fragen.
Ja, irgendwas wollte ich fragen, es fällt mir auch sofort wieder an.
Nee, Andi wollte was fragen. Oder wolltest du mir erzählen von deiner D-Box?
Nee, ach so, du zahlst richtig Asche dafür, hm? Und was zahlst du denn dafür?
60 Mark im Monat.
Och, Mann, du bist ja reich.
Da könnte man ja richtig ein paar Stunden Internet filmen.
Wie viele zusammenhängende Filme guckst du denn so im Monat ungefähr? Ich meine, wenn es zehn sind, dann ist das ja okay.
Nee, da sind viel mehr.
Viel mehr?
Guckst du denn am liebsten an die?
Ja, nee, also ich schau sehr viele Filme an und guck viel Fußball. Ja, genau, Spiele sind nur Sport.
Echt ein wichtiger Faktor bei der Geschichte.
Dann kannst du demnächst die Champions League gucken, weil Möldoch steigt ja bei Kirch ein und dann wird gemutmaßt, dass man Dienstags die Champions League gucken kann.
Dass der TM3 noch abstreitet, ne?
In der letzten Saison kam es ja über Premiere Digital.
Ja, ich weiß.
Da hast du aber... Jetzt muss ich über Bayern angucken.
Weiß ich nicht, wir müssen da noch mal eine Sendung machen, die heißt dann Brot und Spiele und dann reden wir vielleicht dann noch mal über die Inhalte, ne? Ich finde das ein bisschen fast erschreckend, so. Also ich meine, Entschuldigung, ich bin halt irgendwie so ein Mensch, der irgendwie so Fußball und sportliche Berichterstattung irgendwie, ich halte das irgendwie für, keine Ahnung, irgendwas zwischen überflüssig oder so.
Sehr französisch auch gerade. Ich meine, gut, inhaltlich kann man nochmal reden. Sport interessiert mich persönlich auch nicht, aber es ist nun mal so, dass es sehr viele Leute interessiert. Ist ja auch okay, finde ich, habe ich überhaupt kein Problem mit. Besser als wenn Charles-Bronzen-Filme auf Nummer eins legen, überall. Kann ich dir erklären, wer das ist. Jedenfalls was mich noch interessiert, also man kann ja eigentlich, der Vorteil an dem, dass du jetzt 60 Mark immer noch bezahlt hast, die Filme werden nicht durch Werbung unterbrochen. Also ist ja für mich wirklich ein Grund, keine Filme mehr zu sehen im Fernsehen, weil es nervt.
Das ist der Hauptgrund.
Also ich gucke mir keine Filme an, wo Werbung kommt, irgendwo privat oder so.
Was würde denn passieren, wenn jetzt da trotzdem Werbung laufen würde? Würdest du dann sagen, okay, dann bezahle ich auch keine 60 Mark mehr dafür?
Nee, dann zahle ich es nicht mehr.
Na ja, das würde ich auch nicht machen. Sag mal, weißt du, dass es jetzt auch Kanäle gibt, die du mit deiner D-Box nicht gucken kannst, die aber trotzdem im digitalen Fernsehen ausgestrahlt werden?
Ich hab mal gesehen, es gibt ja immer die Sender-Auflistung da. Und dann heißt es immer so schön, ja, kann ich den Schlüssel werden?
Ja, ja, genau. Weißt du, was das für Kanäle sind?
Das sind ein paar ausländische. Ja, genau.
Die Telekom, die strahlt das jetzt aus, das nennt sich Television. Und die sind die ersten, die jetzt irgendwie eigene Kanäle auch ausstrahlen, außer Kirch, die verschlüsselt sind. Und die Telekom, die war da ganz clever, die haben nämlich die Technik von Kirch genommen. Also das heißt, du gehst jetzt in einen T-Punktladen und kaufst dir eine T-Media-Box, was eine LED-Box ist mit einer anderen Karte. Und auf der Telekom-Karte, da kannst du irgendwie Premiere gucken, aber du kannst halt eben diese zusätzlichen Dinge gucken irgendwie. Wäre das was für dich? Also weil du da ja noch 10 Kanäle mehr gucken kannst. Na ja eben, tolle Sachen. Was ich meine, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Es gibt jetzt einen zweiten Player, das ist die Telekom. Das ist auch ganz interessant, warum. Kann man vielleicht später nochmal drauf eingehen, wenn wir irgendwie auf die Kabelnetze eingehen. Es ist tatsächlich momentan so, dass so ein bisschen Bewegung in den Laden kommt und dass mehr Player auf den Markt kommen. Also auch Bertelsmann wird nächstes Jahr kommen.
Ich muss dich kurz unterbrechen bitte.
Oder ist das mit dem MHP oder?
Ja, ja genau.
Der Mann steckt immer ein bisschen, wenn er von Playern redet, dann meint er damit nicht die Abspielgeräte, sondern die Konzerne, die mitspielen. Ich versuche mal zwischendurch, ich frage mich immer, ob man noch den Faden mitkriegt.
Ich höre den ganzen Tag so eine Scheiße.
Die Wertungen kamen von ihm selber jetzt. Ich hätte das nicht so genannt. Andy, haben wir die wichtigste Frage beantwortet? Danke dir. Mal gucken, wie viele digitale Filmmenschen es noch gibt in dieser Stadt. Beziehungsweise, das ist ja gar nicht eine Stadt. Wir senden ja rund um die Welt.
Die D-Box hat da uns empfangen, ist das cool. Na, ich hab sowas noch nicht zu Hause.
Ich hab sowas auch nicht zu Hause, ich brauch's auch nicht.
Ja, ich mein, wenn du in Ulm wohnst und möchtest den ORB hören.
Dann kann ich ja auch über einen Satellitenempfänger hören.
Naja, mit einer D-Box.
Also ich finde, für mich ist es, ich hatte kurz mal Premiere, weil ich dachte, das würde es bringen, weil mich die Werbung halt genervt hat und ich hab das dann echt abgeschafft. Es hat mich völlig genervt. Die Filme sind einfach, wenn ich da wenigstens Filme kriegen würde, die ich noch nicht in der Videothek kriege oder so. Das ist ja dann irgendwie noch später als in der Videothek.
Nee, vor allem ist es genau das Gleiche. Da kommt dann ein guter Film und der Rest ist auch nur Short, nur Beatridges.
Und vor allen Dingen, solange ich das nicht wirklich on-demand habe, solange ich mich nicht abends um, weiß nicht wann immer, ich bock darauf hab, um halb zehn dahinsetzen kann und sagen kann, ich will jetzt Marathonmann gucken, durchscrolle bis M und dann sage ich...
90% der Leute wollen Blue Movie gucken.
Kann sie ja, auch okay. Ist ja scheißegal, ob ich Marathonmann gucken will oder Blue Movie. Ja, aber ich will es dann haben, wenn ich es sehen will, ohne Werbung. Aber selbst da muss ich mich doch an die Zeiten halten.
Ja klar, so nach 23 Uhr halt.
Für Blue Movie. Ja, Premiere... Mehr oder weniger Softpornos nachts.
Also ich mein, ist auch alles geschnitten.
Womensch mein linker Kanal sagt. Jetzt versuch's nochmal. Hallo, wer ist da? Hier ist Chaosradio. Jo, Radio. Hat mit Hören zu tun. Du musst reden.
Ja, wegen eurer Sendung geht ja auch viel Hören. Ihr habt ja gefragt, was man so hat. Also ich höre euch hier so persönlich auch über die D-Box. Ja, ist eigentlich in Ordnung.
Wo bist du denn?
Äh, Unna, ist in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Reichweite nicht schlecht heute.
Allerdings.
Können wir ein paar Leute aus dem Ausland anrufen?
Was machst du sonst mit der D-Box?
Ja, alles Mögliche gucken. Aber eigentlich ist die D-Box nicht so das Ideale, finde ich.
Also du zahlst auch stramm 60 Muck im Monat?
Ja, die zahlen, also das zahlen ja meine Eltern.
Also gibt es keinen, der hier irgendwie D-Box umsonst guckt?
Also ich hab ja schon einiges über die D-Box im Internet zugelesen, was ihr da vorhin auch erwähnt habt mit den Basten an so, dass man das US so flashen kann. Und was mich jetzt interessieren würde, wisst ihr eigentlich, ob es da irgendwelche internen Kopierschutz gibt, falls man versucht, irgendwelche Filme aufzunehmen von der D-Box?
Hier sitzen die Experten.
Wir reden gleich nochmal über das Conditional Access, also die Verschlüsselung, die die D-Box macht. Aber Kopierschutz, glaube ich, kann man sagen, gibt es so nicht. Ist das Makrovision? Aus der Scasi-Schnittstelle kommt doch eigentlich MPEG aus.
Ist das Makrovision? Hallo, hier, gibt es einen Kopierschutz oder kann man es aufnehmen aus der D-Box?
Na ja, also soweit ich weiß, ist da ein Videoencoder drin, der Makrovision kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob der tatsächlich eingeschaltet ist, ob das vom MPEG-Strom abhängig ist, das manchmal nie ist. Aber kann man sich Makrovision-Decoder hinklemmen. Was viel interessanter ist, dass man mit einer umgebauten Software auch eine Festplatte anschließen kann und zumindest den Audio-Teil auf diese Festplatte aufnehmen kann. Angeblich arbeitet die betreffende Person am Videoteil. Das Schicke ist, dass man damit die Daten digital aufnehmen kann. Das heißt, man hat dann einen Qualitätsverlust beim Kopieren. Man hat dann so etwas ähnliches wie eine DVD, die man nicht in einen DVD-Player legen kann. Aber auf einem Rechner mit einem DVD-Player kann man sie sich durchaus angucken.
Ja, oder hat eine CD-ROM mit MPEG-2 drauf. Also eine DVD haben die Leute ja noch nicht. Wie viele Stunden passen drauf, MPEG-2 auf eine CD-ROM?
Das geht so, das sind 20 Minuten ungefähr.
20 Minuten, also braucht man irgendwie für einen Spielfilm, wenn man schon 5 CDs ist. Ja Leute, große Festplatten, Brenner und 5 CDs.
Ja, wo ihr gerade jetzt wieder hier die Sache mit den CDs erwähnt. So, Filme auf CDs. Das ist ja so eine Sache, aber so ein Movie bekommt man ja auf 2 CDs runter.
Ja, MPEG-1, also Video-CD. MPEG-2 ist halt bessere Qualität und man braucht 5 CDs. Und Kirch sendet mit MPEG-2.
Da kannst du natürlich hinterher umwandeln, was bei einem 1, 5 Stunden Film wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen dauert. Also muss schon ein sehr guter Film sein, damit sich der ganze Stress lohnt.
Ja, aber eine große Platte ist ja nicht mehr so teuer.
Stimmt.
Wie viel Stunden MPEG-2 kriegt man auf eine große Platte?
Na ja, was kosten Platten heutzutage für 500 Mark, kriegt man glaube ich 25 GB, da gehen 5 Filme drauf. Also Schweicher kosten ungefähr 100 Mark pro Film, bis man sie auf irgendein billigeres Medium kriegt.
Und was würdest du dann als nächstes machen? Also was ist das billige Medium deiner Wahl?
Schwierig, DAT wahrscheinlich. Da geht genau ein Film drauf, kostet 20 Mark die Kassette.
MPEG-2, ja?
MPEG-2.
Ja, das ist die Lösung für den Hausgebrauch.
Ja, dann gehen wir mal weiter.
Vielleicht ruft da noch jemand an, der irgendwie auch so eine T-Wox hat, aber da keiner durch Strafgebühr zahlt.
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaosradio.
Ich hör euch schon die ganze Weile zu. Hier ist der Martin, ich ruhe euch aus Köln an.
Hallo Martin, aus Köln.
Wie empfängst du uns?
Wir können einen kleinen Wettbewerb starten, wer am weitesten weg ist.
Ja, ich hör euch im Moment über Real Audio, aber leicht versetzt. Ich hab mir jetzt erstmal gestoppt, hier, damit ich nicht durcheinander komme.
Oh, wieso? Mach mal an wieder.
Das ist grauenhaft, da kann man nicht mehr sprechen, ich kenn das.
Kannst dir selber Fragen stellen dann.
Ne, und zwar hat eben der eine Kollege angerufen, der sich ein DVD-Laufwerk angeschafft hat. Und da hat die halt gesagt, die Filme wären noch so teuer. Und ich hab jetzt seit ein paar Wochen auch halt ein DVD-Laufwerk für den Computer gekauft. Und ich hab mich mal umgeguckt und ich muss sagen, die DVD, die ist schon verdammt billig geworden.
39, 49?
Das sind so die neuen Filme, aber wenn du jetzt hier mal so normale, schon was älteren Titel holst oder so, die kriegst du schon für 20 Mark. Also das ist nicht mehr so und die Videotheken, die verleihen die jetzt auch zu ganz normalen Preisen, also ja 2 Mark, 2, 50 in den Tag und so.
Aber was ich ja nicht so richtig verstehe, der Vorteil, also der Durchbruch des Videorekords, das war ja auch ganz klar die Tatsache, dass ich selber was aufnehmen kann aus dem Fernsehen und so weiter. Ich hab unter anderem bei die Laserdisc ja, dachte ich zumindest, das ist in Europa gefloppt, weil ich einfach nur ein Abspielmedium hab und auf das, also um die bessere Qualität wirklich zu sehen, braucht man einen extrem guten Fernseher, der auch eine entsprechende Größe hat und so weiter. Also ich sag mal, für meinen Hausgebrauch mit ab und zu mal einen Film gucken irgendwie, ist mir ehrlich gesagt, und es gibt schon sehr schlechte VHS-Kopien, aber ist mir ehrlich gesagt wurscht, ob ich jetzt ein gutes Video gucke oder dann irgendwie diese Klarheit im Bild hab oder so. Ich brauch einfach nicht nur einen Player, sondern auch einen Recorder. Ich verstehe die Motivation nicht so richtig, sich einen DVD-Player zu kaufen.
Ich sag mal, ich leime halt viel Filme aus, ich guck wenig Fernsehen, weil wegen dieser Scheißwerbung. Und da will ich auch mal vernünftig gucken. Und ich nehm die auch nicht auf. Guckst du einen Film ein, zwei Mal an oder so, dann ist das Thema auch gegessen.
Das würdest du aber auch machen, wenn du Video on demand hättest. Also wenn Bertelsmann sagen würde, zahl zwei Mark irgendwie und das Ding...
Wenn die Grundgebühr nicht dabei wäre auf jeden Fall.
Genau, ohne Grundgebühr. Das machen die ab nächstes Jahr.
Und wie gesagt, dann leistet du dir die Filme halt aus, guckst sie an, vernünftig in der Qualität. Ich hab hier auch noch kein AC3, aber ich hab jetzt im Moment nur Dolby Serena und so weiter. Und das ist ein Unterschied auf jeden Fall.
Und du hast dann aber auch entsprechendes Equipment, was den Fernseher angeht, also den Monitor, dass du das halt auch...
Nee, im Moment guck ich noch auf den 17 Zöller. Ich bin jetzt aber gerade dran, ich will mal gucken, ich will mir einen Videoprojekter holen. So einen etwas zahlbaren, sag ich jetzt mal, der immer noch ein gutes Bild bringt.
Ach so, stimmt, du bist ja am Computer, hast ja einen DVD-Hoffwerk gekauft. Sag mal, guckst du dann alleine?
Ja, das haben wir damals, ja.
Naja, weil ich finde, das ist durchaus eine Frage. Also Filme guckt man auf der Couch oder davor? Also so den Computer, der steht ja meistens am Schreibtisch, der ist nicht so richtig bequem.
Nee, ich hab nur eine einzelne Bude hier praktisch, das ist nicht so das Thema.
Dann kann man die Couch auch mal kurz umdrehen, ist okay.
Also es ist schon blöd hier auf einem 17 Zoll. Effektiv, wenn du dann noch hier den White Screen drin hast oder so, dann sind da noch die fetten Balken. Kannst zwar zoomen, aber naja, sag ich mal, ich gucke jetzt erst mal immer, dass ich mir eine vernünftige Grafikkarte hole, wo ich TV-Ausgang habe, dann gucke ich mal entweder Fernseher dran oder Projektor oder so, da bin ich also jetzt erst mal am Schauen. Und vor allem ist es beliefert, wenn ich mir jetzt für 1500 Mark oder so einen vernünftigen Abspieler hole da, dann hab ich immer noch keinen Fernseher und kann gar nichts dahinten dran.
Also ich würde empfehlen dir einen Beamer zu holen, weil wenn du einen großen Fernseher holst, dann macht der wieder Interlace-Bild und wo du das DVD sowieso auf dem Computer abspielst, hast du Non-Interlaced und das sieht natürlich besser aus und das kannst du auf dem Beamer einfach erhalten.
Ja, ich muss mal gucken, ich bin es jetzt selber noch nicht. Ich hab jetzt mal verschiedene Dinge angeguckt, gibt es zum Beispiel von Sony schöne Videoprojekte schon für unter 1000 Mark, ob der was taugt. Ob ich mir das im Fernseher hole oder halt den Projekt, ich kann es nicht sagen, keine Ahnung. Mal schauen.
Also es muss natürlich VGA-tauglich sein, damit du was hast von dem Non-Interlaced-Spaß.
Naja, aber die kosten dann auch. Den Sony, den FD1 oder so.
Ein guter Fernseher kostet auch Geld.
Ja sag ich, der kostet ja bestimmt 3000 Mark oder so. Das ist ein bisschen happig. Mal schauen.
Wofür ihr so euer Geld ausgeben?
Ja, wenn ich Andros am Brief mag.
Ey, sag ich auch immer. Frag mich nicht, wofür ich meine Kohle ausgebe, das ist noch schlimmer. Martin, ich dank dir.
Achso, übrigens, mit dem MPEG-2, wie hieß das da eben, Kopiershots da, ne? Was ist da Macrovision 20 drauf? Auf den DVDs kommen die jetzt so langsam und auf dem MPEG-Stream werden die den auch mit ausstrahlen, schätze ich.
Naja, auf DVDs hast du sie, aber das ist so, dass da nur ein Bit im Header steht, das sagt, jetzt mal bitte Macrovision einschalten und insofern...
Das interessiert vielleicht so ein Standalone-Player, aber Computer, ne?
Den Computer interessiert das einfach nicht. Und wir hatten es von DVB, also digitalem Fernsehen, und da gibt es soweit, ich weiß, dieses Macrovisions-Bit nicht. Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Also kann sein, dass, aber... Ja, naja, wie gesagt, auf den Computer interessiert es ja nicht. Und wo du Kopierschutz bei DVDs sagtest, da... Irgendjemand meinte es schon, es gibt da diesen Speedripper, mit dem man DVDs kopieren kann. Da ist mittlerweile auch der Sourcecode für das Verschließungsverfahren aufgetaucht. Und das ist wirklich lächerlich trivial zu knacken. Also die Keys sind 40-Bit lang. 40-Bit kann man auf seinem eigenen Rechner errechnen. Dann haben sie eine Sicherheitstür eingebaut. Also es gibt verschiedene Player-Keys, die in verschiedenen Player-Software drin sind. Sodass wenn irgendwie einer kompromittiert wird, in dem Speedripper steckt zum Beispiel nur einer von 400 möglichen Keys drin, der dann halt mit neueren DVDs nicht mehr geht. Aber es ist möglich innerhalb von 18 Stunden sämtliche existierenden Keys rauszufinden. Also...
Auf dem normalen Rechner?
Eben, eben. Dafür kann man dann alle DVDs kopieren. Also sie haben da versucht, so einen Kopierschutz einzubauen, und es ist glorios in die Hose gegangen.
Na gut, den Vorteil, den sie halt noch haben, ist die Größe. Das ist halt für den Speicher halt zahls im Moment noch.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, und ob ich jetzt nur drei CDs hab, oder wechsel die?
Na ja, ich mein, das Internet entwickelt sich auch. Also das ist auch ein weiteres interessantes Thema. Demnächst wirst du zu Hause irgendwie an deinem Kabelfernsehanschluss Kabelmodem anschließen und hast einfach mal 2 Megabit.
Ich hab mal bei Alias L bei der Telekom vorführen lassen.
Ich meine, genau, und was weiß ich, wenn dein Kumpel irgendwie auch an so einer Leitung hängt, dann liegt bei ihm halt eben Terminator 2 auf der Platte und du guckst es dir an. Du brauchst es nicht auf deine eigene Platte zu speichern, weil es liegt ja bei ihm. Dementsprechend muss eigentlich nur jeder einen Film, vielleicht seinen Lieblingsfilm irgendwie abspeichern. Aus seiner Homepage sagen, ja, den Film gibts bei mir irgendwie und dann können die Leute sich bei ihm anwählen. Also muss nicht jeder alles speichern.
Mit dem Tripod an seiner Tür klingeln.
Naja, ich mein, das ist ja so eine Sache. Sie haben jetzt gerade diese Woche wieder 500 MPEG MP3 Sites geschlossen, aber es wird immer irgendwelche Leute geben, die ihren Lieblingsfilm irgendwann mal zeigen und vielleicht ein paar Leute, die wissen, dass der in dem Moment gezeigt wird auf dem Internet.
Ja, und diese Zahlen mit 500 Sites geschlossen, die finde ich auch immer extrem zwiespältig.
Abgemahnt, abgemahnt.
Wahrscheinlich sind das 500 HTML-Seiten, die sich auf drei Sites verteilen.
Sie haben irgendwie 500 Leute abgemahnt, mit Geldstrafen bis zu 2000 Mark, wenn sie nicht aufhören und so.
Wie, dann zahlt man 2000 Mark und kann weitermachen?
Wieso denn, das kostet dich doch eh nicht.
Zahlt sich dich mag und hast den ganzen Tag einen Freifahrtschein.
Okay Martin, ich dank dir.
Alles klar, haut rein, mach weiter so.
Schönen Abend.
Bitt mal zu, dass du eine bessere Sendezeit kriegst.
Morgen ist um 8, Frühstücksradio.
Ich find's 10 Uhr.
Da haben wir dann andere Anrufer, nicht so gute wie euch.
Ach, fühlt sich schon, also ich mach seit glaube ich 12, 13 Jahren Radio und ich finde das fühlt sich schon irgendwie klasse an, wenn man weiß, dass Leute eigentlich überall sitzen könnten.
Ja.
Dass jetzt jemand anruft und verstehe die Sprache gar nicht, die der spricht. Und dann steigt er an und sagt mir in seiner Sprache, dass er unsere nicht versteht. Ist doch großartig.
Ja, das ist vielleicht noch ein anderer Effekt auch. Über Sattel Lead kann man den Kram ja nicht nur in Deutschland empfangen.
Ja, sag mal die Vorwahl für Deutschland vielleicht noch mit der Telefonnummer.
Ach, die weiß jeder. 0049 ist die Vorwahl für Deutschland. Und wir haben seit zwei Minuten Fritz-Info laufen.
Attentat. Der armenische Ministerpräsident Sagesianis wurde heute bei einem Anschlag in der Hauptstadt Jerewan erschossen worden. Mit ihm starben mindestens sechs weitere führende Politiker. Mehrere bewaffnete Männer hatten während einer Parlamentsdebatte das Feuer auf die Anwesenden eröffnet. Sie nahmen zahlreiche Personen als Geiseln. Beschluss. Die 140 Waggonbauer in Fetschow haben erneut ihren Betrieb besetzt. Die Belegschaft will die Blockade bis zum 3. November fortsetzen. An diesem Tag soll es in Berlin eine Demonstration für den Erhalt der Arbeitsplätze geben. Eskalation. Nach den bisher schwersten Luftangriffen auf Grozny hat ein russischer Kommandeur die Erstürmung der tschechischen Hauptstadt angekündigt. Präsident Jelzin hatte zuvor erklärt, Russland wolle ein für allemal die Zentrale des internationalen Terrorismus in Tschechien zerstören. Prüfung. Das oberste Gericht der USA untersucht, ob der elektrische Stuhl als Hinrichtungsmethode verfassungswidrig ist. Die Richter wollen den Berufungsantrag eines Todeskandidaten aus Flowey da hören. Die für heute geplante Hinrichtung des verurteilten Mörders wurde abgesagt. Fußball zunächst. In der Champions League spielten am Abend Leverkusen gegen Rom und Dortmund gegen Rotterdam jeweils 1 zu 1 unentschieden. Basketball in der Euro League verlor Eiber Berlin gegen Panathinaikos Athén, wie berichtet 54 zu 73. Doping-Urteil des DFB Sportgericht hat die Spielsperre für den Nürnberger Fußballprofi Thomas Ziemer auf ein halbes Jahr festgelegt. In erster Instanz war Ziemer zu einer neunmonatigen Sperre verurteilt worden. Er hatte ein verbotenes Muskelaufbaupräparat eingenommen. In dieser Nacht bleibt es unverändert meist trocken bei 9 bis 7 Grad am Tag. Dann bewölkt teils auch heiter 12 bis 15 Grad. Keinerlei Meldungen aus Berlin und Brandenburg. Wir wünschen weiter eine gute Fahrt.
Matthias Karkow mit dem Fritz. Die Musik, die ihr hört, kommt von Claude, denn der steht hier an den Decks. Hinter dem Mikrofon sitzt der Chaos Computer Club. Genauer gesagt Martin, Christian, Andi und Andreas. Durch die Sendung führt, das hat man früher gesagt, Johnny am Mikrofon. Und ihr hört Chaos Radio Computer Blumen bleibt bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Das Thema, im weitesten Sinne digitales Fernsehen oder wir haben vorhin gesagt, eigentlich kann man auch sagen nur noch das Netz, denn das wird alles verschmelzen natürlich. Würde man, wie es jetzt bei euch ist, würdet ihr eher sagen, das Internet geht ins Fernsehen oder das Fernsehen geht ins Internet?
Das Netz ist der entscheidende Faktor. Die große Frage lautet, wer bekommt das Kabelnetz der Telekom? Weil das Kabelnetz der Telekom ist das Netz. Und wir unterscheiden in Netze...
Wer hat jetzt gar meisten geboten?
Keine Ahnung, sieht so aus. Also ich tippe auf Deutsche Bank.
Das sind doch Amis, die jetzt nochmal irgendwie drauf gelegt haben.
Ja, die Theorie lautet ja irgendwie, dass der BND nicht so besonders daran interessiert ist, dass das deutsche Kabelnetz in nicht deutsche Hände übergeht.
Glaub ich gerne.
Ja, glaub ich auch.
Ja, aber der Witz daran ist ja eben, dass das bisherige Breitbandverteilnetz nicht mehr ein Breitbandverteilnetz ist, sondern dann zum Internet wird.
Jaja, sicher. Also man kann sich das so vorstellen, wenn du irgendwie zu Hause deine Kabelbuchse hast, irgendwie dann bist du einfach an einem großen Ethernet dran.
Also letzten Endes ist es so, dass wird das Fernsehen zum Internet oder das Internet zum Fernsehen beides, muss man eigentlich sagen. Also auf der einen Seite hat man die Kabelanschlüsse, wo traditionelles Fernsehen rauskommt, wo man jetzt halt auch Internet mitmachen kann. Und das heißt halt auch Video und Demand, neben den bisher bekannten Internet- und Fernsehgeschichten. Und auf der anderen Seite hat man das klassische Internet, früher Modem und ISDN, jetzt gibt es ADSL. Das ist ja auch schnell genug, es nur über Video zu machen. Wenn man sozusagen ein klassisches Internet hat, dass jetzt auch fernsehen kann. Und letzten Endes wird es einfach nicht mehr unterscheidbar sein. Man wird da eine Dose in der Wand haben, da wird IP rauskommen und zwar genug. Und was jetzt dahinter hängt, ist egal. Es ist einfach dasselbe.
Und es ist dann auch egal, wo der Fernsehsender oder der Fernsehserver dann steht. Genauso wie bei WWW-Servern, die können überall in der Welt sein. Dann haben wir unsere Zuhörer nicht nur in Köln und in Süddeutschland sondern auch nur in Australien. Wir können es nicht wissen, wo es hingeht.
Ich hab gerade so eine Vision, weil du gesagt hast, da kommt massig IP aus der Wand. Wie wo ich so digitale Punkrocker am Cotty mir vorstelle, die nach einer IP fragen. Nicht nach einer Marke. Ich würde ganz gerne, bevor wir weiter telefonieren, die Rufnummer ist natürlich immer noch offen für euch. 0331 für Potsdam, dann die 7097110. Wir suchen immer noch den weit entferntesten Zuhörer, die weit entfernteste Zuhörerinnen. Die müssen dann 00 49 331 7097 110.
Ich würde gerne wissen, wer uns über sein GSM-Funktelefon hört.
Zum Beispiel mit Real Plug-in. Wer hat das 1.0.10? Und hat ein Plug-in installiert. Und dann würde mich noch interessieren, weil wir gesagt haben, das läuft alles zusammen. Es gibt ja viele Leute, die beklagen, dass das Internet der Kommerzialisierung unterliegt. Im Moment natürlich wird es andere Bereiche immer weiter geben. Da, wie wir gerade auch schon gehört haben, auch der Fernsehsender demnächst irgendwo stehen kann, genauso wie der Fernsehserver, genauso wie der Web-Server irgendwo stehen kann. Seht ihr in dieser ganzen digitalen Zukunft eine Lücke für kleinere Anbieter? Sind das tatsächlich größere Chancen oder ist es so, dass nach wie vor das Geld alles schluckt?
Das ist im Wesentlichen eine Frage der Bandbreite, die der Konsument von sich zum Rest der Welt bekommt. Also ob er ein Konsument ist oder ein Teilnehmer in diesem Netz. Denn wenn die Rückbandbreite schnell genug ist, dass man da auch senden kann, dann reicht das aus. Also momentan, klassisches Streaming im Internet läuft halt so, dass jeder eine Verbindung aufbaut und wenn man 10.000 Leute bedienen will, braucht man ganz dicke Leitungen und ganz viele Server. Aber es gibt eine nette Erfindung, die heißt Multicast. Und Multicast bedeutet halt, dass man die Sachen nur einmal losschicken muss. Und alle die, die es sehen wollen, die kriegen das halt. Es wird halt unterwegs auf den Routern aufgeteilt, auf die verschiedenen Leitungen, wird überall hingesendet. Das heißt, die Bandbreite, die ich zum Empfangen von Fernsehen brauche, ist gleich der Bandbreite, die man zum Senden von Fernsehen braucht. Und dadurch werden die Unterschiede zwischen Sender und Empfängern extrem nivelliert.
Ich hab ja ein Problem damit, liebe Telekom, ich hätte vielleicht schon längst TDSL-Kunde sein können, wenn ich nicht diesen Quatsch da sehen würde, dass ich halt einen Download hab mit bis zu, weiß ich, wie viel M-Bild, aber ein Upload, der ablenkt.
Da hast du was abzulohnen. Ja, du ja, du würdest sofort Radio machen von zu Hause aus.
Aber genau, das ist im Moment auch die Verständnissgrenze, die eben zwischen den beiden Welten, und ich rede deswegen von Welten, weil die Leute, die Fernsehen machen, die haben halt traditionell auch ein Gesellschaftsbild im Kopf, wo sie überhaupt nicht über Menschen reden, sondern wo eben der Begriff Konsument, der Andreas eben auch mal rausgerutscht ist, einfach der ist bei denen so verankert, mit denen kann es auch nicht darüber reden, dass das potenzielle Sender sind, sondern die sagen, da sind die Sender, da sind die Empfänger, und der Konsument, der will doch gar nicht.
Ja, aber sie halt eben an der Wertschöpfungskette in der Stufe sitzen, wo sie Rechte kaufen, etwas auszustrahlen.
Ja, aber das ist die dritte Fraktion. Also ich würde sagen, es gibt einmal die Fraktion der Leute, die traditionell vom Fernsehen kommen und die da überall Konsumenten sehen und die entsprechend die Rückbandbreite auch genau so viel dimensionieren, dass man da eben Gaffem und Demand machen kann. Dann nennst du die Leute, die von der Netzseite kommen.
Ja, weißt du, was ich schlimm finde, dass du sagst, dass die Leute, die traditionell vom Fernsehen kommen, irgendwie die Leute zuballern wollen und durch sie Geld verdienen wollen. Weil das war nicht immer so. Ich meine, die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender haben einen Auftrag. Und der Auftrag heißt halt eben, irgendwie Leute gleichmäßig irgendwie mit einer ganzen Bandbreite von Informationen, Unterhaltungen zu versorgen.
Für dich Sport, Übertragung, Informationen sind für dich die Autozone.
Nein, was ich so krass finde, ist, dass du irgendwie die Fernsehmacher so hinstellst, irgendwie als ob sie die Leute total verarschen wollen. Weißt du, warum es dazu kommt? Da die Privatfernsehmacher halt eben im Fernsehen das Geschäft sehen. Wenn die Leute nicht das Geschäft sehen würden, das große Geschäft irgendwie anderen Leuten Filme zu schicken oder Sachen zu zeigen, dann wäre es einfach irgendwie ganz, würde es ganz anders aussehen, die Landschaft?
Nein, aber ich meine, es gibt einmal die Leute, die du gerade beschrieben hast, die irgendwie Geld machen wollen. Und auch die, die Geld machen wollen, denen kann man dann erklären, okay, es gibt ein neues Geschäftsmodell. Und das Geschäftsmodell beruht darauf, dass die Interaktivität am Endgerät, sprich die Möglichkeit als Sender da reinzugehen, eben auch attraktiv ist und die Leute sogar bereit sind, dafür zu bezahlen. Das sind die Geschäftsleute. Aber ich erlebe zumindest in den politischen Debatten, wo ich dann von Jungs wie euch auch mal reingeschickt werde, erlebe ich doch viele Leute, die haben einfach ein bestimmtes Bild von wie Gesellschaft funktioniert. Und für die ist digitales Fernsehen nichts weiter als die konsequente Umsetzung von analogen Fernsehen, nämlich die Möglichkeit dem Konsumenten...
Ich warte darauf, dass die Mittelaufsage so mit seiner Battlesman-Stiftung irgendwie kommt er jetzt irgendwie dem Auftrag nach mit seinem AOL-TV nicht nur irgendwie Leute abzuzocken und dazu zu bewegen, irgendwie bei ihm Bücher zu kaufen, sondern er gibt ihnen for free auch etwas, was ihnen wirklich nützt. Da warte ich drauf.
Du meinst, das ist der Moment, wo er dann bei Battlesman rausgeworfen wird, weil sie sagen, sorry wir wollen Geld verdienen.
Nein, du kannst ja sowas zum Beispiel auch wieder zum Geschäftsmodell machen, aber ich glaube, ich sitze da so ein bisschen zwischen den Stühlen, weil hier gibt es schon zwei verschiedene Ansatzpunkte. Ich glaube, das was Andi meint und sagt, jeder ist auch Sender und so, das ist ein bisschen schön gemalt leider, denn es gibt, also jetzt mal ganz blöd gesagt, es gibt den offenen Kanal. Also es gibt einfach nicht so viele Sender und Spieße.
Was wir im Internet haben, ist doch in erster Linie mal ein niederschwelliger Zugang zur Möglichkeit, da selbst auch Inhalte reinzustellen und das ist ja nicht so, dass es nichts passiert. Ich sage nicht, dass jetzt jeder gleich irgendwie super interessante Urlaubsbilder zeigen wird oder dass ich mich wirklich dafür interessiere, was du irgendwie mit deinen Kindern auf Tahiti erlebt hast. Aber ich sage, dass die Möglichkeit und der Kulturraum, der da im Internet entstanden ist, ja schon auch zeigt, dass da noch irgendwie was anderes ist. Insofern stelle ich mir die Frage...
Was war das in der Mitte?
In der Mitte?
Was du eben in der Mitte gesagt hast.
Tahiti?
Es gibt ja schon einen Unterschied zum offenen Kanal. Zum offenen Kanal muss ich hingehen.
Ja, da musst du Formulare ausführen und irgendwann hat mich da diese Schiefer-TV...
Ja, ist alles okay, wenn du einen vernünftigen Rückkanal hast, dann machst du das aus von deinem Sofa aus.
Genau, und ich mache es auch nur dann, wenn ich den Eindruck habe, ja wieso, der Punkt ist doch einfach, hat das Netz überhaupt die Möglichkeit oder muss ich 800 Millionen Mark dafür bezahlen, wie ein Fernsehsender auch? Wenn ich mal jetzt gerade zufällig was Interessantes der Menschheit mitzuteilen habe.
Naja, ich mein, das war ja im Grunde auch das Thema. Deswegen ist das Netz so wichtig. Wer das Netz besitzt, bestimmt die Gesetze wie abgerechnet wird. Was ganz interessant ist, ist beispielsweise, dass es deinem Internetprovider etwas bringt, wenn du etwas sendest. Er verdient damit Geld, weil er sendet nämlich das, was du sendest, aus deinem Netz raus in andere Netze und bekommt Geld von den anderen Netzen irgendwie, dafür, dass er ihnen etwas gibt.
Das darfst du aber im Grunde schon keinem mehr erzählen.
Nee, das darfst du keinem mehr erzählen. Das Netz ist Peering. Also Peering-Abkommen sind die am besten gehüteten Gesetze irgendwie überhaupt.
Aber de facto nämlich die Internet-Provider, denjenigen, die sozusagen senden und Treffegerzeugen, auch noch Geld dafür abknüpfen, dass sie die Geld verdienen.
Andy, erklär mal richtig Peering.
Na Peering ist ja nichts weiter als die Bedingung, unter denen die Internet-Service-Provider ihre Netzknoten und ihre Backbones miteinander verkoppeln.
Naja, also im Prinzip teilen sich Internet-Provider in zwei Sorten. Das sind einmal die sogenannten, oder ich nenne sie mal, Provider-Endkunden, die halt eine Leitung zu irgendeinem Backbone haben und das an 20.000 Teilen ihren Kunden weiterverteilen. Und die zahlen für die Bits, die da durchgehen. Und die großen Provider haben mehrere Leitungen und sind untereinander miteinander verbunden. Und die bezahlen sich nur die Differenz. Also sie zahlen sich natürlich einmal den Betrag in der einen Richtung für den Traffic, dann bezahlen sie sich den Betrag in der anderen Richtung für den Traffic. Und dadurch zahlen sie im Endeffekt nur die Differenz. Das heißt, wenn sie genauso viele Server wie Clients haben, ist das ein Null-Zoom-Spiel. Aber sie können natürlich den Leuten diese Server-Housing verkaufen, trotzdem noch Geld für den Traffic abnehmen und den Leuten, die als kleiner Provider hinten dran hängen.
Auf Deutsch gesagt, wenn Bertelsmann oder die Deutsche Bank das Kabelnetz kaufen würden, dann wären sie der größte Internet-Provider Deutschlands.
Der potentiell?
Potentiell größte Internet-Provider Deutschlands.
Das hängt davon ab, ob sie das verstehen, oder?
Ja, sie haben es verstanden. Sie haben es verstanden, Bertelsmann.
Das Internet in aller Richtung veranstalten.
Bertelsmann hat gesagt, aufgrund unserer Kompetenz in AOL und mit unserer Firma Mediaways schlagen wir vor, wenn das Kabelnetz irgendwo von irgendwem gekauft ist, dort als Internet-Provider aufzutreten. Wenn die das Geschäft beispielsweise exklusiv machen würden, dann hätten sie die Besitzer des Kabelnetzes verarscht. Weil genau damit kann man Geld verdienen, dass man eben auf diesem Netz Internet, sprich IP, aus der Dose provided.
Zwei Fragen beschäftigen uns in dieser Ausgabe des Chaosradios.
Erstens, sind die Scheiben hier kugelsicher?
Und zweitens, wo ist der Fördner?
Und drittens, welchen Grad der Interaktivität wollen wir wirklich?
Ja und wo ist der nächste Hörer?
So viel zum Thema, jeder kann senden, Andy. Du hättest sofort sagen können, ey hier drei Mikros.
Aber Johnny, da hast du mich vielleicht auch falsch verstanden. Ich erlebe ja selber, was passiert ist, weil ich diesen Kulturraum im Internet ja tatsächlich noch aus der Zeit kenne, wo tatsächlich die Leute drin waren, eigentlich nur die, die die Technik noch bis zu einem gewissen außerirdischen Grad beherrschen mussten. Und dann kamen halt irgendwann diejenigen, die dann erst mal sehr abfällig als Mäuseschubster und Legaszeniker bezeichnet wurden, die das Ganze eben eher von clicky-bunty kennen und dann eben mit ihren entweder zaghaften oder eben überhaupt nicht zaghaften Kommunikationsversuchen, sowas wie Newsgroups, erstürmt haben. Und ich meine, man kann das positiv sehen.
Was sind da noch einige, da muss man froh sein.
Ja, da gibt es ja irgendwie diese nette Art und Weise zu formulieren, die Stimmung steigt, das Niveau sinkt, also wie es halt auf guten Partys auch ist. Aber gut, was wir hier gerade erlebt haben, das war ja auch eher ein Beispiel für, na...
Und keiner weiß, was wir gerade erlebt haben.
Das war ein Hörer und er hatte eine Frage, es ging irgendwie um die Soundqualität der D-Box, ob das irgendwie übersteuert ist oder... Ich hab's nicht genau mitgekriegt.
Ob der Pegel auch so hochgezogen ist über den Privatfernsehen?
Kannst du das mal bitte beantworten, weil wir haben gesagt, wir beantworten das.
Ich weiß die Antwort auf die Frage nicht, um ehrlich zu sein, aber es ist ja so, dass die Privatsender, besonders bei ihren Werbung, den Gesamtsound-Eindruck sehr viel lauter haben als den Rest des Programms und auch als die öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehsender.
Das heißt, die heben die Werbung akustisch hervor.
Ja, und ProSieben übersteuert jetzt in Dolby Surround.
Aber wäre das nicht auch eine Methode, relativ automatisch das zu erkennen und dann einfach irgendwie sonst was damit zu machen?
Also bei ProSieben gibt es eine sehr hübsche Automatik neuerdings, die senden ja jetzt in AC3, das heißt in Surround-Sound, und die ganze Werbung ist natürlich nicht in AC3 produziert, das heißt, wenn man einfach nur AC3 dekodiert und bei normalem Stereo-Sound abschaltet, hört man die Werbung nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist doch das, was wir haben.
Ja, genau, die ProSieben sind echt vorne.
Was seht ihr denn kommerziell gesehen als, ich meine, es gibt ja offensichtlich im Moment nur eine, also, fangen wir mal anders an, wir haben gerade darüber geredet, jeder kann Sender sein und so weiter, das ist aber natürlich immer das Phänomen, oder was heißt Phänomen, spiegel.de wird millionenmal angeklickt, tausendmal bessere Informationen, weil aus besserunterrichteten Quellen.de wird nur 20.000mal angeklickt, weil Marketing, Blablabla, Team dahinter, Geld dahinter. Offensichtlich ist es ja so, wenn man das WWW betrachtet, gibt es als Geldquelle für diese ganzen Sachen, die eine Menge kosten, wenn man Sender ist, also wenn man auf großer Ebene Sender ist. Es gibt natürlich immer den Underground, aber wenn man auf großer Ebene Sender ist, gibt es offensichtlich als Geldquelle ja nur noch die Werbung.
Ja, also ich meine zwei Sachen. Zum einen Sendetechnik wird richtig billig, also das heißt jeder kann richtig gut senden.
Soundtechnik ist aber auch schon richtig billig.
Ja, das wird alles richtig billig.
Es gibt auch immer Ausnahmen, aber trotzdem sind es die großen Acts, die auf den Markt gepusht werden.
Das entscheidende ist doch eigentlich wer was zu sagen hat, kann was sagen und wer gut ist, wird gehört oder gesehen oder gelesen.
Zum Beispiel, ich mache mal ein Projekt mit, das heißt Beta-Lounge, www.betalounge.com, da könnt ihr euch angucken. Und da laden wir DJs ein, die einmal die Woche bei uns 4-5 Stunden Musik spielen. Die wollen dafür auch kein Geld, weil die haben Spaß daran, mal von einer kleinen Gruppe Leute zu spielen und im Internet zu spielen, wo sie weltweit gehört werden. Und wir haben Archiv von allen Shows zu den letzten drei Jahren. Wir haben ungefähr 30.000 Zuhörer pro Woche. Und das Ganze läuft rein privat und finanziert sich eigentlich gar nicht, weil das auch kaum was kostet.
Also ich bin natürlich da komplett auf dieser Seite, aber ich will jetzt in eine andere Position einnehmen, weil 30.000 Hörer pro Woche ist nichts.
Ja und? Das kostet ja auch nichts.
Ja, aber was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass es irgendwann den Punkt geben wird, dass du irgendwas finanzieren musst.
Interessiert dich die Anzahl der Hörer oder wer dich hört?
Nein, mich persönlich interessiert vielmehr, wer mich hört. Ich bin Beta-Lounge kenne ich, finde ich auch großartig. Das ist jetzt keine private Meinung von mir, sondern die Frage war ja darauf gerichtet, wie kann man irgendwas, was größer angelegt ist, finanzieren, außer Werbung? Sobald du auf der Beta-Lounge riesengroß Werbung schalten musst, um zum Beispiel eine Technik zu finanzieren oder so.
Es gibt schon alternative Modelle. In Amerika gibt es zum Beispiel die Geschichte der Free-Radios. Die machen das so, dass die halt ein- oder zweimal im Jahr einfach ihre Hörer komplett dazu aufrufen, denen nochmal eine Mark 50 zu spenden. Man muss dazu aber auch sagen... Ja, das ist mehr oder weniger Shareware. Da kommen also zumindest in New York die 26th Handel, also die amerikanischen Hacker, die machen auch einmal im Monat, glaube ich, eine Radiosendung oder sogar einmal die Woche, ich weiß es nicht, auf einem New Yorker Radiosender, der, ich war da mal, das ist alles ein bisschen verranster als hier. Die Technik ist sicherlich nicht das neueste. Die spielen auch nur urheberrechtlich freie Musik, das heißt nur klassische Musik, die, ich glaube, mindestens 30 Jahre alt sein muss oder irgendwie sowas. Also das Musikprogramm ist einfach von einem ganz anderen Stern.
Das ist das älteste als 1969.
Ganz gutes Konzept aber.
Und die rufen halt zweimal im Jahr die Leute ihre Hörer dazu auf, da irgendwie Code zu senden. Das funktioniert so. Ich meine, was die halt machen, ist ganz extrem viel Talkradio. Also ganz viele Leute anrufen zuvort. Die haben da teilweise acht Leute gleichzeitig, wo dann noch einer im Studio sitzt und die irgendwie versuchen, das zu generieren.
Das ist billiger Content. Ja, das ist vielleicht auch der bessere Content, keine Frage. Also ich bin da großer Anhänger von...
Und ich meine, du hast natürlich recht, wenn du sagst, es gibt irgendwie auch noch so was wie den Auftrag, gemeinschaftliche, gesellschaftliche Realitäten zu bilden. Das, was die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen an und für sich mal als Aufgabe hatten. Aber diesem Auftrag kommen sie ja sowieso. Und dadurch, dass das Privatfernsehmechanismus im Prinzip irgendwie stark abgefärbt hat, kommen sie ja sowieso nicht in dem Maße nach, wie wir uns das mal vorgestellt haben.
Was man sagen kann ist, der Markt entscheidet. Wir werden sehen. Wir werden sehen, ob diese kleinen Talk-Radios...
Ach, das ist ein ganz schieser Satz, finde ich.
Wir haben hier richtig Kapitalisten.
Ich meine, jahu, guck dir jahu an. Guck dir an die Websites, die wirklich Geld gemacht haben, weil sie viele Klicks drauf hatten. Am Anfang gab es einige, die waren einfach gut und die sind herzreich. Und es gibt immer wieder Leute, die haben was zu sagen.
Waren sie gut oder waren sie schnell?
Beides. Die großen Zeit, die haben sich das Geld nicht unbedingt dadurch geholt, dass sie jetzt direkt die Hits in Münzen umgewandt haben, sondern dass sie an die Börse gegangen sind, gesagt haben, hier liegt die Zukunft und hier mit der Quote.
Und sie machen trotzdem Millionen, Milliarden Miese im Jahr. Das muss man auch mal sehen.
Ich meine, es wird einfach nicht mehr so einfach zu sein. Ich heiße jetzt hier Berlin Radio 1 irgendwie und hab keine Ahnung, ich hoffe, das gibt's nicht. Und ich hab irgendwie so meine 300.000 Rentner pro Stunde. Und ich baller die irgendwie zu mit Werbung für Klosterfrau Melissengeist. Und ich kann davon leben irgendwie. Oder ich mach halt eben irgendwie meinen Internet-Talk-Radio und kann auch davon leben.
Ja, aber der Markt entscheidet. Der Markt entscheidet. Der Markt entscheidet ist eine ganz große Gefahr. Wenn der Markt entscheidet, dann gibt es keine Innovation, keine Kultur mehr.
Nee, nee, nee, Johnny, also da bis jetzt war wirklich ganz stark wieder auf diesem Urheberrechtsgeist, wie Eigentumstrip.
Nee, nee, nee, auf dem Auftragstrip, auf dem öffentlichen Auftragstrip.
Nein, ich bin einfach auf dem Trip, dass es die Möglichkeit geben muss, und die haben wir ja im Netz und wahrscheinlich dann auch weiterhin und hoffentlich weiterhin, dass es die Möglichkeit geben muss, für mehr Leute zu senden. Also das, was Andi vorhin meinte. Weil, wenn nur der Markt entscheidet, ist wirklich das Problem. Ich mein, das, ihr könnt doch umfragen und so selber sehen.
Wer die Netze besitzt, entscheidet, weil der kann entscheiden, wie teuer es ist, zu senden.
Genau. Und außerdem kommt dazu, dass...
Was kostet das überhaupt? Also...
Du kannst zum Beispiel, ich hasse ja so Meinungsumfragen und Statistiken, weil, wenn du Leuten die Wahl gibst zwischen Sachen, die sie kennen, dann können sie nur davon das wählen. Aber Innovationen oder völlig neue Sachen, die man sich noch gar nicht vorstellen kann, wären so immer unmöglich. Und wenn der Markt entscheidet... Ah, ist wahrscheinlich dann Demokratie. So, wir haben nebenbei hier ein paar Exit-Tabellen ausgefüllt mit einem neuen Business-Modell für dir. Wer macht Geschäftsführung?
Nein, erst mal wie heißt der Sender?
Ach, ganz schwierig.
Also, bei Mexikacos gibt's ja Big Time Television. Das ist nämlich so ein Punker, der auch immer Rotten schlecht im Musikkleider spielt, der einen Witz-Fernsehsender in seinem, ja ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie er hieß, der aus einem Wohnwagen heraus eben einen kleinen Piraten-Sender macht und im Grunde genommen, gut, der macht sich auch nicht irgendwie die Mühe so und kämpft halt aber gegen Channel 23. Wie gehen die Jungs, die im Aussichtsrad ganz oben auf dem Hochhaus sitzen und sagen, diese Stadt wird durch das Wahnsinn regiert und der Krieg geht um die Einschaltquoten und wir müssen irgendwie den Zuschauer mit physischer Gewaltsynoth dran hindern, umzuschalten.
Habt ihr euch den Net mal angeguckt? Das ist ein ganz interessanter Ansatz. Die machen so Soap-Operas für Minderheiten oder Randgruppen, die in Amerika schon wieder eine ziemliche Menge ausmachen. Und die laufen nur im Netz. Also da gibts halt, weißte nicht, per alle möglichen Streaming-Formate.
Oder was ist eine Soap für eine Randgruppe?
Es gibt zum Beispiel eine Soap, die heißt Fear of a Punk Planet. Die Serie ist geschrieben und gespielt von einer amerikanischen Punk-Band namens The Vandals, die wir vielleicht einige kennen. Und die schreiben diese Soap-Opera. Also an sich, wo du so sagst, was ist das für eine Zielgruppe? Dann wieder mit Bensby Green Day und Offspring und so. Natürlich inzwischen eine ziemlich große Zielgruppe. Und der Witz daran ist, dass du denkst, das hat so offene Kanalqualität, hat es aber nicht. Das ist höchst professionell produziert. Läuft halt auf diesen kleinen Fenstern. Und du weißt genau, sobald die Bandbreite da ist. Also technisch ist es auf jeden Fall schon so, dass man das auch Fullscreen senden kann. Und dann gibt es bei denen zum Runterleihen mehrere doppelstellige Megabyte-Zahlen. Irgendwie so einen Videoclip, so einen Quicktime, der sozusagen der Werbetrailer von denen ist. Der ist so dermaßen professionell produziert und so dermaßen amerikanisch gesprochen. Ich glaube der Geschäftsführer ist irgendwie 22, sieht aus wie 15. Und da siehst du dann irgendwann so ein Warehouse, wo die sitzen. Und das ist so gigantisch, dass du weißt, dahinter steckt irgendjemand mit richtig, richtig, richtig viel Geld. Und jede Woche, wenn du da auf die Seiten kommst, ist da ein Sponsor mehr drauf. Und die Sponsoren heißen halt nicht, weiß ich nicht, Müller. Die heißen Intel. Die heißen Ford Motor Company. Die heißen, weiß ich nicht, Giga Megabell. Und ähm, ja, interessanter Ansatz, mit diesen Randgruppen auf jeden Fall Geld zu verdienen. Und zwar auf Big Scale. Hast du geguckt mal? Ey, ist das, achso, du bist am Chatten.
Sagst du mal kurz noch, wer die Quotenmacher sind?
Im Radio, keine Ahnung.
Wie? Also Spielfilme habt ihr nicht, Sport auch nicht und Sex auch nicht.
Also ich hab da persönliche Einstellungen zu. Ich weiß nicht, wer die Quotenmacher wirklich sind.
Womit wird dann in Berlin Radio verdient? Welches Radio in Berlin verdient Geld und womit?
Ich glaube keins.
Na doch, ich denke, dass die Privaten z.B. zahlen sehr viel weniger, geben sehr viel weniger Geld für die Sendungen aus und haben durch die Werbung natürlich Einnahmen. Keine Ahnung, was da die Zahlen sind. Ich finde allein schon das Verfahren, die Zahlen festzustellen, sehr zweifelhaft. Da gibt es dann so stichpunktartige Umfragen und danach wird dann beurteilt und Radio-Reichweiten werden in Hörern pro Stunde gemessen.
Also meine Tochter hat mir erzählt, meine Tochter ist sieben, da gibt es einen, der ruft morgens immer irgendwelche Leute an, holt die aus dem Bett und erzählt ihnen irgendeine Scheiße und verarscht die so lange, bis er ihnen irgendwann mal sagt, dass er vom Radio ist. Und so was senden die da? Also ich hab irgendwann gesagt, das ist nicht lustig.
Ich denke, es gibt nur ungefähr zwei Sender in Berlin, wie das sein könnten. Ich höre ja so wenig Sender. Ich kenne ja nur oft zwei insgesamt im Raum Berlin. Aber ich glaube, dass so Fiesheit, ich meine Howard Stern ist ein Beispiel in Amerika, dass so Fiesheit und Leute einfach echt Scheiße behandeln, schon Quotenbringer sein kann. Wir können das mal probieren. Scheiße, die sitzen sicher nicht dran.
So lange bis jemand dran ist.
Keine Opfer gefunden.
Huft an Leute, huft an. Johnny macht euch fertig.
Nee, ich habe das aufgegeben. Ich habe vor Jahren mal versucht, so eine Hass-Sendung zu machen.
Die wüste Hörer-Beschimpfung.
Und es gibt ja durchaus Leute, die können das, aber ich glaube, ich bin da nicht dran.
Du meinst, du rufst mal solches.
Hörer, wir lieben euch. Ihr seid unsere Hörer.
Hallo Hörer, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaosradio.
Wir haben keine Hörer mehr. Hier haben wir alle an Radio 1 verloren.
Das sind irgendwelche Störungen im Kabelnetz.
Hallo Hörer, wer ist da? Hier ist dein Radio. Hallo, wer bist du denn?
Ich bin Thomas.
Thomas, hallo. Von wo rufst denn du an?
Ich, aus Sachsen.
Boah, wie empfängst du uns?
Einfach so.
In Sachsen kriegst du Fritz noch an manchen Nippen.
Über meine Satellitenanlage und angeschlossen, irgendwie ist das komisch.
Du hast dein Radio an der Satellitenanlage angeschlossen?
Ja, bist du dann schon digitaler Filmgucker?
Ähm, nein, ich... Also, mein Nachbar, mein Nachbar, die haben da alle Teleclub kostenlos.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist das österreichische Premiere sozusagen, analog.
Ach so.
Ah, wieso kostenlos?
Ja, weil es diese Verschleißung ist wie Premiere.
Einfach schwarz, die schauen es schwarz einfach.
Wie machen die das?
Die haben da Kabel und das ist reingeschaltet worden.
Wie? Von dem Kabel-Fernsehsender?
Ja, genau. Der hat das gemacht.
Ja, aber die haben nicht irgendwie so gekräckte Chipkarten oder so was, mit denen sie alles...
Haben die nicht.
Kennst du jemanden, der das macht?
Bei uns haben sie es auch gemacht, bloß in meinem Ort. Und der ist aufgeflohen, er durfte 15.000 DM strafen.
Erzähl, erzähl, was war das für eine Geschichte? Die ist ja spannend.
Ja, der hat das, glaube ich, drei Jahre gemacht. Und dann haben sie ihn irgendwie erwischt. Der hatte Premiere reingeschaltet.
Wo hat er das reingeschaltet?
In das Kabelnetz.
Sind das Nachbarschaftskabelnetze, so privat aufgezogen?
Da hat er natürlich viele Zuschauer, ne?
Ja, also das war relativ viel. Die haben es alle geschaut, aber die haben eine Strafe dafür gekriegt.
15.000, ja.
Ok, jetzt müssen wir einen kurzen Realitätscheck machen. Da guckt ein kleiner Kreis von Leuten, drei Jahre lang Kosten aus Premiere. Derjenige, der es initiiert hat, muss 15.000 Mark Strafe zahlen. Die Frage ist, haben die anderen jetzt alle zusammengelegt, damit das für jeden dann irgendwie 10 Mark im Monat waren?
Nein, ich glaube, die haben dreimal mehr bezahlt oder so.
Die haben dann nur was gegeben gehabt, ich weiß noch nicht wie viel.
Also er hat dafür kassiert?
Ja, er hat ein bisschen was abkassiert dafür.
Achso, ok, dann werden wir das nehmen.
Und das hat er dann irgendwie abgegeben halt, oder?
Nein, er hat gar nichts abgegeben, er hat es sich behalten.
Ja, aber im Moment, du sagtest, er hat 15.000 Mark da irgendwie abgeben müssen.
Ja, dann auch.
Rest hat er behalten.
Ok, dann hat er wahrscheinlich da immer noch einen guten Schnitt gemacht.
Thomas, ich danke dir für diese heiterne Geschichte. Das kommt drauf an, wie man cool definiert.
Andreas.
Auf jeden Fall war die Geschichte ziemlich ok.
Erzähl mal, wie manche Leute umsonst Premiere World gucken.
Na Premiere World, vielleicht sollten wir mal Premiere Classic anfangen.
Das war also ziemlich das erste, was verfügbar war.
Diese Analog-Receiver-Karten für PCs sind in letzter Zeit sehr populär geworden.
Vint.TV heißt das ja.
Vint.TV. Und das aus dem ganz einfachen Grunde, weil es Programme gab, die das analoge Premiere-Bild, kennt man ja so verschlüsselt, man erkennt so ein bisschen was, aber halt nicht wirklich, wieder zu einem Bild zusammengesetzt haben, was man sich richtig angucken konnte. Und zwar aufgrund der da vorhandenen Muster. Also so wie man das ein bisschen was sieht, so kann man zusammenrechnen, wie die Zeilen so ein bisschen zusammenpassen könnte. Daraus kann man dann wiederum zurück errechnen, was für ein Key in Frage kommt, und dann wird das Bild entschlüsselt. Und damit gucken eigentlich ziemlich viele Leute analog Premiere.
Diese Karten haben sich sehr gut verkauft, irgendwie genau seit der Zeit, als es diese Software im Internet gab.
Genau. Vorher haben die Leute gar keinen Sinn darin gesehen, auf den PC Fernsehen zu gucken, und dann war das plötzlich damit attraktiv. Da gab es Leute, die haben sich extra einen PC gekauft, um das zu machen. Wenn man sich fragt, sind 3000 Mark für einen PC, da kann man bestimmt sechs Jahre von Premiere gucken.
Aber nicht umsonst.
In Bezug auf Legalität und Illegalität gibt es tatsächlich verschiedene Fraktionen. Es gibt genauso, wie es diese Spießbürger gibt, die sich irgendwie wirklich bei jeder roten Ampel lange aufhalten müssen, egal ob sie Fußgänger sind oder was auch immer, gibt es auch die, die Gesetze einfach nur des Prinzipes weges brechen, egal ob es irgendwie Sinn macht oder nicht. Also da ist gesellschaftliche Spannung noch nicht durchgehend erreicht.
Besonders wenn du so von zu Hause von deinem Drehstuhl aus machen kannst, natürlich extrem praktisch.
Einfach mal ein bisschen illegal sein wegen dem Kribbeln.
Wir waren doch nicht beim Digitalen Premiere.
Was ist das denn?
Ich glaube ich muss das hier erstmal feststellen. Das funktioniert dann leider nicht mehr.
Die Technologie, die müsste auch mal wieder refinanziert werden.
Da sind wir dann beim Thema Saurung.
Leute, zahlt eure GSZ-Gebühren, dann gibt es hier ein neues Mikro.
Genau. Ja, hatten wir vorhin schon erzählt, dass die digitale Fernsehung im Wesentlichen MPEG-2 ist. Bei den ganzen Pay-TV-Geschichten wird das verschlüsselt. Der Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus heißt Simulcrypt. Der ist auch überall gleich. Was nicht gleich ist, ist wie die Chipkarten funktionieren, die in den Boxen drinstecken. Auch die Module, die die eigentliche Entschlüsselung machen, mit der Chipkarte reden, sind naturgemäß anders. Bei der D-Box ist es das Erdeto-Modul, die Erdeto-Karte. Es gibt jetzt mehrere Punkte, an denen dieses System angreifbar ist. Auf der einen Seite kommt der verschützte Strom rein in dieses Conditional Access-Modul, auf der anderen Seite der Entschlüsselte raus. Dazu redet er alle 10 Sekunden mit der Chipkarte, lässt sich von der Chipkarte den aktuellen Key geben, entschlüsselt das damit. Den ersten Ansatz, den man machen kann, ist einfach die Kommunikation zwischen dem Verschlüsselungsmodul und der Chipkarte abzuhören. Blocker ist zwei verschiedene Geschichten. Eine Geschichte ist die, dass man einfach den Key anguckt, der im Klartext rauskommt, den aufzeichnet, das verschlüsselte Signal auch aufzeichnet und das dann hinterher auf der Platte entschlüsselt. VCL nannte sich das Verfahren, glaube ich, früher, bei den analogen Geschichten, also es ist noch analog verschlüsselt, da hat man dann einen Videorekorder genommen, das verschlüsselte Bild auf den Videorekorder aufgezeichnet dazu, wo die Chipkartenprotokolle mitgezeichnet und konnte dann mit einem Programm das simulieren. Dann hat man so einen kleinen Simulator, den man statt der Chipkarte reingeschoben hat, der dann die Daten entsprechend wieder zurückgespielt hat, so als wäre es eine echte Chipkarte.
Wann war das, in welchen Jahren?
So 1994, 1995 war das populär.
Und nach nur fünf Stunden hatte man...
Na ja, es ist eher eine Geschichte für Bastler gewesen damals noch. Das kamen dann später Leute, die das ganze kommerziell verkauft haben, die diese Chipkartenadapter verkauft haben, die dann auch angefangen haben, komplett nachbauten, diese Karten zu verkaufen. Also das kann man natürlich auch machen, dass man herausfindet, wie diese Chipkarte funktioniert und die Chipkarte nachbaut. Also so richtig einfach kopieren geht nicht, wie man sich das vorstellt, so wie Copy von A nach B, sondern man muss da schon... Da ist ein Prozessor drin in der Chipkarte, man muss dieses Programm rausholen, verstehen, nachprogrammieren, man muss die Keys extrahieren und so weiter und so fort, alles mit ein bisschen Aufwand verbunden. Und sowas kann man dann bei einigen Versehhändlern unter dem Ladentisch kaufen.
Wie ist das jetzt bei Odeto?
Bei Odeto gibt es das alles. Odeto ist ein relativ schlechtes Verfahren, das nicht besonders gut gesichert sind.
Das ist aber doch das, womit jetzt momentan Premiere World gesendet wird.
Das ist richtig. Und dementsprechend gibt es auch Leute, die das gucken, ohne die 60 Mark im Monat zu überweisen.
Was haben die dann?
Na, das, was die Leute auch haben, die überweisen.
So eine Karte? Zahlen aber nicht?
Nö.
Magie.
Die Zahl der Angriffe ist noch höher. Und gerade bei Odeto funktioniert viel. Man kann auch diese Karten, die werden normalerweise vom Sender aus zentral ein- und ausgeschaltet. Und was man machen kann, ist einen sogenannten Blocker zwischen die Karte und das Gerät tun, das Ausschaltesignal abfiltern, dann wird die Karte einfach nicht mehr ausgeschaltet. Das heißt, man hört auf zu bezahlen, die schalten die ab, das Abschaltsignal bleibt im Filter hängen und man kann weitergucken.
Diesen Blocker gibt's ja im Internet, ja? Nee, das ist Hardware.
Kannste auch, wie gesagt, beim freundlichen Elektronikhändler nebenan und am Ladentisch kaufen. Und die nächste Möglichkeit, die auch bei Odeto funktioniert, ist, dass man die Karten selber freischalten kann. Man kann also diese freischalten Nachrichten, die normalerweise vom Sender kommen, auch fälschen.
Das heißt, wer jetzt noch zahlt, ist selber schuld.
Oder ein ehrlicher Mensch.
Also gerade bei der, also intern bei der Diskussion angelangt, ob ehrlich gleich gesetzeskonform ist.
Oder anders formuliert, ob jemand tatsächlich ehrlich ist, wenn er dafür bezahlt. Es könnte auch sein, dass er einfach nur sich an die vorgegebenen Empfehlungen hält, um Stress zu vermeiden oder so faul ist, sich eine Piratenkarte zu besorgen.
Das ist immer die Frage, ne, ob du, wenn du für etwas bezahlst, irgendwie einen angemessenen Preis dafür bezahlst. Das hat einfach was mit Geld zu tun, wahre gegen Geld, ja. Also zahl ich jetzt irgendwie meine Gebühren oder meine Abo-Gebühren beim digitalen Fernsehen oder guck ich einfach so, ist Information frei oder kostet sie etwas? Chaos Computer Club sagt, Information, die alle angeht, etwas ist frei. Das heißt, sie soll auch allen zugänglich gemacht werden. Private Information dagegen muss geschützt werden. Das heißt, man soll uns nicht unbedingt in unsere Festplatten und Gedanken und sowas reingucken. Wer sagt irgendwie, ob ein Musikstück, was Peter Gabriel geschrieben hat, frei ist oder etwas kostet? Es sagt die Firma, die die Rechte an Peter Gabriels Musik besitzt, die sagt irgendwie, das kostet was. Und irgendwie jemand anderes, also zum Beispiel ich, singen was und sage, das kostet nichts.
Wobei wir hatten Mixmaster Morris ja auch schon mal hier mit Lala vertreten und so und der zum Beispiel. Der stellt seinen Kram komplett irgendwie ins Netz. Hat das mit seiner Plattenfirma irgendwie entsprechend abgeriegelt?
Er stellt seinen Kram nicht komplett ins Netz.
Ja doch, da ist eine ganze Menge von ihm nötig. Also zumindest, also ich hab mal, als er mal aufgeregt hat, hab ich mal dat mitlaufen lassen und er hat gesagt, er hat im Prinzip kein Problem mit, aber wenn ich das macht, dann hab ich damit auch die Verpflichtung übernommen, das gleich ins Netz zu stellen.
Klar, das ist ja auch cool. Also da ist jetzt Public Enemy so ein ganz gutes Streitbeispiel dafür, finde ich, weil die haben ja doch, also in Anführungsstrichen, sehr früh, natürlich lange nicht so früh wie viele völlig unabhängigen Bands, aber dann so von den Bands, die schon auch ganz gezielt mit Konzernen zusammenarbeiten, sehr früh mitgekriegt, aha, MP3, und sind auf diesen komischen MP4, dieses Fake-Format gesprungen und so. Und die haben halt im Netz zumindest für eine Menge Wirbel und auch in der Offline-Presse, weil man kannte den Namen, für eine Menge Wirbel gesorgt, weil sie hier, MP3 ist die Zukunft und bla und so. Im Grunde genommen haben die nichts anderes gemacht, hat einen verdammten Song ins Netz gestellt und dann irgendwie gesagt, CD dazu kannst du hier bestellen. Also Public Enemy, nichts gegen Chuck D den ich sehr schätze, aber weiß nicht, da hat schon jemand auch sehr viel Marketing gemacht.
Ich guck mal, die eigentliche Antwort auf die Frage ist doch einfach, wer die Rechte an etwas hat, dadurch, dass er es geschaffen hat, oder dadurch, dass er es gekauft hat von jemandem, darf entscheiden, was er dafür will. Und er verteilt das jetzt irgendwie, und in dem Moment, wo ich entscheide irgendwie, ich habe es von ihm meinetwegen gekauft, gäbe es aber eben allen Leuten im Internet for free, mache ich mich gegenüber ihm irgendwie strafbar, weil ich halt eben sein Recht, es zu entscheiden, verletze. Und das ist eine ganz klare Sache. Also das heißt, es ist geklärt. Die Frage ist halt eben nur, ob die Menschheit so viel Moral und so viel Ethik hat, dass sie halt eben darauf Rücksicht nimmt. Weil ich meine, es ist ja ein ganz kleines Verbrechen. Einen Mausklick und das Ding ist irgendwie auf dem FDP-Server und jeder kann es sich runterladen.
Ja, aber vor allem ist es eine andere Kultur, weil das, was im Internet ja diesbezüglich bisher herrschte, war Geschenkkultur. Wie jeder gibt etwas hinein und jeder kann sich nach Herzen Lust bedienen. Und ich hätte schon auch Lust auf einen virtuellen Sozialismus oder sagen wir von mir aus, einen virtuellen zentralisierten Sozialismus, wie Robert M. Wilton es nennt, wo ich dann einfach sage, ok, zwischen den und den und den Leuten, die ich irgendwie kenne, da ist einfach irgendwie Herr Gartner.
Möglicherweise schafft das Netz genau dieses System, also auch das Gesellschaftssystem gerade jetzt irgendwie.
Genau, nur die Übergangspunkte, die sind im Moment mit Maschinengewehren, Geldschein und was nicht allen bedroht.
Maschinengewehre?
Naja, ich meine, wenn wir jetzt hier so 15.000 Mark sich hier hören, die klingt ja noch irgendwie okay so, ne, aber also ich...
Das ist wirklich schwierig, weil die Frage ist, hätten wir in so einem virtuellen Sozialismus dasselbe... Es gibt einfach Sachen, die werden nur angeboten, weil durchaus eine kapitalistische Motivation dahinter steht. Und weil es ist nicht immer nur alles schlecht, also zu 95 Prozent, aber es gibt immer noch 5 Prozent, wenn man so denkt, würde das der eigene Antrieb selber hervorbringen, denn nur sozialistische Gedanke.
Naja, ich meine...
Sicherlich nicht. Also ich streite ja gar nicht ab, dass es auch irgendwie einen Sinn gibt, jemanden was dafür zu bezahlen, dass er irgendwie einen guten Film, ein gutes Buch, sich irgendwie Arbeit und Mühe gemacht hat und so fort. Die Frage ist eben nur, ob dieser Anspruch der repräsentativen Instanzen, die jetzt gerade wegbrechen, nämlich die G-Mas, die Musikverleihende, die jetzt alle irgendwie tierisch rumstressen und sagen...
Die Frage ist doch, ob du das, was momentan sowieso passiert, kontrollieren kannst und regulieren kannst. Die Aussage, die Tatsache ist, technisch kannst du es nicht kontrollieren. Das heißt, es gibt keine Möglichkeit, das Kopieren von digitalen Tonträgern oder Filmen zu verhindern.
Es sei denn, du schaffst es halt, der Menschheit so ein kollektives schlechtes Gewissen zu verpassen.
Du tust etwas Unrechtes, wenn du diese Maus begehst.
So sieht es nämlich aus. Wie endet man dann? Tragisch.
Er ist gestorben.
Dann soll man Toten nicht so...
Entschuldigung, ich war erst auf dem Stand, das ist ja so schlecht.
Nein, wir wollen auch nicht blasphemisch sein.
Kein schlechter Geschmack in der Sendung.
Aber trotzdem wollen wir jetzt diese halbe Stunde mit einem kräftigen Hossa abschließen.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
0, 30 Uhr, pünktlich.
Das kann vorkommen. Attentat, der aminische Ministerpräsident Sackesian ist bei einem Anschlag im Parlamentsgebäude erschossen worden. Mit ihm starben mindestens sechs weitere führende Politiker. Die Täter nahmen zahlreiche Personen als Geisel und verteidigten im aminischen Fernsehen den Anschlag als patriotische Aktion. Arbeitsplätze, der Pharmahersteller Berlin Chemie will noch in diesem Jahr weitere 180 Mitarbeiter einstellen. Am Standort in Atlashof sollen zwei neue Produktionsstätten entstehen, heißt es. Umsatz und Gewinn des Unternehmens steigen eigenen Angaben zufolge in diesem Jahr stärker als erwartet. Eskalation. Nach den bisher schwersten Luftangriffen auf Grozny hatte ein russischer Kommandeur die Erstürmung der tschechischen Hauptstadt angekündigt. Präsident Jelzin hatte zuvor erklärt, Russland wolle ein für allemal die Zentrale des internationalen Terrorismus in Tschechien zerstören. Prüfung. Das oberste Gericht der USA untersucht, ob der elektrische Stuhl als Hinrichtungsmethode verfassungswidrig ist. Die Richter wollen den Berufungsantrag eines Todeskandidaten aus Florida hören. Die für gestern geplante Hinrichtung des verurteilten Mörders wurde abgesagt. Fußball in der Champions League spielten am Abend Leverkusen gegen Rom und Dortmund gegen Rotterdam. Die Ergebnisse jeweils eins zu eins unentschieden. Es gibt mal in der Euro League Verlust Berlin gegen Paranet Janssen. Athen 54 zu 73.
Wetter.
In dieser Nacht mal ist trocken bei Temperaturen zwischen 7 und 9 Grad am Tag. Dann bewölkt Heißheiter 12 bis 15 Grad.
Verkehr.
Aus unserem terrestrischen Sendegebiet keine Meldungen weiter. Gute Fahrt.
Das war Matthias Karkauf mit dem Fritz Kurz Info.
Freitag, 29.
Fritz öffnet wieder die Big Beat Boutique.
Chaos Radio bei Fritz, die Musik kommt von Claude, der die ganze Zeit schon in dieser Sendung auflegt. An zwei CD-Spielern und zwei Platten-Spielern, die man leider nicht alle gleichzeitig hören kann. Und vom Chaos Computer Club sind Martin, Christian, Andy und Andreas im Studio. Johnny, ein Mikrofon für Fritz und für den CCC. Ich bin irgendwann am Anfang dieser Sendung, vor vier Jahren inzwischen übrigens, am Anfang dieser Serie hieß es irgendwann mal, ich wäre Ehrenmitglied. Ich habe nie eine Aufnahmebestätigung bekommen vom CCC. Was ist da eigentlich los in der Buchhaltung? Hups, mach mal eure Mikrofon an.
Du bist beim CCC, aber nicht beim CCC e.V.
Und nur, dass du unstrukturierte Sätze reden kannst.
Hast du noch lange nicht, dass ich aufgenommen bin?
Schade.
Ich dachte, das reicht schon. Man muss nämlich nur eine CCC-Mitgliedschaft, mindestens fünf Jahre Radio machen oder so.
Man muss die Hose runterlassen.
Ach, das hab ich schon tausendmal versucht. Frag Andi.
Hat mir das geklappt.
Das ist eher eine Anspielung auf ein internes Ritual, das man nicht mit den tatsächlichen Hosen zu tun hat.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz, ganz verweiserver-
Das wird durchaus in die Richtung. Um zum Thema digitale, bewegte Bilder zurückzukommen, Frage zu Beginn dieser letzten 25 Minuten. Warum hat der Videorecorder eigentlich nicht die Filmindustrie zerstört? Und jetzt mal abgesehen, also war die Qualität-
Oh, die Qualität hat der Videorecorder ja auch, die Filmindustrie zerstört, behaupten sie jedenfalls immer. Es ist allerdings in Deutschland so, dass du das Recht hast, eine Kopie zu machen von Filmen, die du in einer Videothek ausleihst, weil du damit ein Gebrauchsrecht irgendwie erwirbst. Und das darf dir nicht verhindert werden. Und das heißt, das hast du auch zeitlich unbegrenzt erworben. Da gab es auch schon eben Anfang der 90er dieses Urteil gegen Makrovision. Aber jetzt machen die doch wieder Makrovision auf Videokassetten und haben auch wieder den Kopiershirt auf DVDs. Wenn ich das richtig sehe nach deutschem Recht, musst du dir von DVDs, die du in der Videothek ausfährst, dann auch Kopien machen dürfen.
Was du auch machen wirst?
Was du auch machen wirst natürlich. Gerade in den letzten zwei Tagen gab es da eine sehr nette Entwicklung. Und zwar wurde eben der Source-Code von einem CSS-Entschlüsselungsprogramm gepostet auf dem Internet. CSS ist eben das Kryptografiesystem, mit dem DVDs so verschlüsselt werden, dass sie offiziell nur auf original Abspielgeräten wiederzugeben sind.
Aber es gibt ja noch die Ländercodes.
Ländercodes sind einmal so codiert, dass eine nordamerikanische CD nicht in Europa wiedergegeben werden kann. Damit der Freund aus den USA nicht den neuesten Star Wars oder Matrix oder sonst was überschickt im Briefumschlag und du dir den dann anguckst, bevor er hier im Kino ist. Das ist schon vor Jahren geknackt worden.
Wie ging das?
Das sind kleine Module, die du in diese Standalone-DVD-Player einbaust.
So wie diese Modchips bei den Playstations?
Genau so, die dann diesen Reaching-Code ignorieren. Das zweite ist eben dieses CSS, das verhindert, dass du eine DVD in einen DVD-ROM-Laufwerk in deinem Computer reinsteckst und dir einfach eine 1 zu 1 Digital-Kopie auf deine Festplatte machst und dann von dort dir den Film anguckst. Beziehungsweise wenn in einem Jahr die Brenner entsprechend im Preis gesunken sind, du dir dann direkt eine 1 zu 1 Kopie auf einen DVD.
Hat die Industrie noch irgendwas auf Lager jetzt?
Ja, jetzt ist eben CSS so ziemlich abgegessen.
Was kommt jetzt als nächstes als Schutz?
Ja, sie haben etwas in Planung. Und zwar wollen sie...
Alle Leute, die legal das kopieren, gar nicht verschießen.
Wir haben ein zweistufiges System. Und zwar wollen sie bei diesen kopiergeschätzten DVDs ein Watermark in das Bild mit reintun. Das macht man, indem man eine gewisse digitale Signatur in die niederwertigsten Bits der Bildinformation mit reinbaut.
Die sieht man nicht, ne?
Mehr oder weniger unsichtbar. Normalerweise ist es dann eben ein erhöhtes Rauschen im Bild. Das heißt, es ist irgendwie schon sichtbar. Auf jeden Fall wird dann das Abspielgerät dieses Watermark erkennen und verlangt dann auch von der DVD, auf der dieser Content ist, dass die Spur leichten Schlangenlinien verläuft. Weil sie auf den kaufbaren Rohlingen nicht sein wird. Das heißt, man kann auf die Spur selbst, auf die Spurlage, ein feines Signal aufmodulieren.
Siehst du, dass das gecracked wird?
Das wird schwieriger werden als das CSS jetzt. Aber sobald bekannt ist, wie dieses Watermarking funktioniert, dann kann man einfach beim Kopieren dieser DVD das Watermarking aus dem Film wieder herausnehmen. Dann ist es nicht mehr watergemarkt. Und auch normale Abspielgeräte werden dann, wenn kein Watermark drin ist, diesen Wobble auf der Spur nicht verlangen. Und so wird es wieder abspielbar sein.
Und es ist natürlich auch so, dass man auf Computern das trotzdem abspielen kann. Auch wenn man es auf seinem Send-alone-DVD-Player vielleicht nicht spielen kann, man kann sich trotzdem eine Kopie auf DVD-ROM oder irgendein anderes Wechselmedium machen. Das ist ja ein Pfeil, das sind Bites. Dann kann man dich mit seinem Play abspielen.
Würde ich nur noch einen Computer nehmen als DVD-Spieler.
Ja, ein Computer ist aber leider ziemlich laut, wenn man ihn im Wohnzimmer steht. Da brummt der Lüfter und die Fersplatte.
Es gibt noch ein anderes Problem, das ist die Software. Du brauchst zum DVD-Gucken auf Computer und Software.
Die haben aber viele Leute.
Ja gut, aber wenn es irgendwann die Auflage gäbe, also dieses Rottermarken, versuchen sie ja auch an der Musik.
Dann ist MPEG-2 ja ein Standard. Und für Standard gibt es immer Standardimplementation. Und da wo es Standardimplementation gibt, gibt es auch verbesserte, freie Implementation. Und man kann sich einfach an MPEG-2-Player aus dem Netz ziehen.
Und gerade wo es eben Software ist, mit Soft ist da das entscheidende Wort.
Wenn der nicht die Auflage hat... Wenn das Fraunhofer-Institut schneller gewesen wäre, in Sachen MPEG-3, dann gäbe es keine Möglichkeit, einfach Player zu schreiben.
Dann hätte sich auch MPEG-3 nicht durchgesetzt. Das ist vor allem ein prinzipielles Problem. Man fragt sich natürlich, sind die einfach nur zu blöd? Verwenden die schlechte Verschlüsselung? Ja, sie verwenden schlechte Verschlüsselung, aber das ist eigentlich gar nicht der Punkt. Der Punkt ist, dass ich mir irgendwann das MPEG anhören muss. Und irgendwann muss ich mir so ein Video angucken. Das heißt, es muss an irgendeiner Stelle zwar noch komprimiert, aber bereits entschlüsselt in dem Gerät vorhanden sein. Und an der Stelle kann ich es immer abgreifen und kopieren. Da können Sie sich ausdenken, was Sie wollen. Das ist einfach nicht zu lösen.
Quod errat demonstrandum. Das war eben gerade der Beweis, dass Kopierschutz unmöglich ist, weil es gibt ein Problem, ein Risikofaktor. Der Mensch, der den Film sehen möchte oder den Ton hören möchte. In dem Moment, wo er den Film sieht oder den Ton hört, kann er den Film oder den Ton kopieren.
Ich bin nicht so ein Come-Caller vor meinem Fernseher.
Aber es geht auch ohne Verluste. Das ist zwar ein bisschen mehr Arbeit, wenn man in diesen Player rein muss, aber wenn der Software ist, ist das machbar. Wenn der Hardware ist, ist das schwieriger, aber immer noch machbar. Das sieht man an den Nachbauten von den Premiere-Karten zum Beispiel. Diese Chips wurden halt unter dem Mikroskop zerlegt und ausgelesen. Das kann man auch mit anderen Chips machen. Es ist also nicht möglich, das irgendwie geheim zu halten.
Die Chinesen haben das übrigens schon längst kapiert, diese Erkenntnis.
Ja, das wollte ich dich gerade fragen. Du bist ja eher derjenige, der die marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien da beleuchten kann. Gibt es denn nicht auch vielleicht sogar die ersten Filmverleiher, also die, die die Filme finanzieren, die sich dessen bewusst sind, dass sie mit diesen technischen irgendwie Lösungen...
Das ist gerade eine ganz große Diskussion in Hollywood. Man hat noch nicht so recht eine Lösung gefunden, aber eigentlich wissen es alle. Ich wollte nur sagen, die Chinesen haben einfach gesagt, was machen die da in Amiland? DVD-Verschlüsselung und sowas. Ist doch nur MPEG-2 drauf. Das heißt, die haben einfach irgendwie Geräte rausgebracht. Die nennen sich VCD, Super VCD Player. Und die gucken da in China wunderbar irgendwie Video-CD. Also es gibt da einen Werbesport, habe ich mir erzählen lassen. Da ist ein ganz alter Mann, der hält irgendwie so ein Gerät in die Luft. Und da steht runter, super, ich kann jetzt immer die neuesten Filme gucken. Und das Tolle ist, das Gerät läuft mit Batterie, weil in unserem Dorf haben wir noch keinen Strom.
Es führt insgesamt trotzdem ein bisschen zurück zu meiner Frage zur Eingang dieser halben Stunde jetzt, weil man muss sich doch wirklich fragen, warum haben die denn, also Kopien, die eine Sache, ich kann, wenn alles überhaupt nicht geht, oder wenn ich zu voll dazu bin, kann ich immer noch die analoge Kopie machen, ich hänge einfach an den Fernseher einen Videorekorder und nehme das Signal so auf und die vielleicht mit dann relativ gutem Equipment gar nicht so sehr sichtbaren, qualitätsunterschiede interessieren mich nicht, so wie die Kassette und auch die Mini-Disc bisher nicht die Musikindustrie und vor allem nicht den kreativen Output der Musiker zerstört hat, hat der Videorekorder nicht den kreativen Output von Regisseuren oder die Filmindustrie zerstört. Warum also diese Riesenangst vor dieser Kopierfähigkeit? Warum muss man...
Naja, ich meine, die Künstler brauchen eigentlich keine Angst zu haben, weil sie haben immer noch Ideen, sie machen immer noch gute Filme und sie werden das immer noch finanziert kriegen, durch ein anderes Modell, was Andreas schon angesprochen hat. Wer im Moment die große Angst hat, sind halt eben die Studios, die Verleiher, die Kinobetreiber, die gesamte Musik- und Plattenfirmen. Die Industrie hat Angst.
Aber beruht dann diese Angst nicht eigentlich auf ein bisschen Unflexibilität, was sozusagen die Veränderung des Geschäftsmodells betrifft?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube gerade die Kinos können bei der ganzen Geschichte nur gewinnen. Wer ist denn irgendwie in der Lage, sich ein Beamer für 5.000 Mark nach Hause zu stellen und ein Dolby Surround-Verstärker für 2.000? Macht nicht jeder, sondern die Kinos stellen sich auch noch immer größere Beamer, immer beste Soundanlagen hin, stellen auch auf digital um, übertragen die Filme von den Studios in die Kinos direkt über Satellit statt, das über Filmrollen zu tun. Und solange das Erlebnis im Kino zu gehen einfach besser ist, als mir das zu Hause anzugucken, werde ich natürlich noch in den Kino gehen.
Ja, das heißt, sie werden irgendwie darauf wechseln müssen, dass sie die Filme weltweit zuerst in den Kinos zeigen und erst dann die Wiederverkaufsmedien, die Zweitverwertung dann auf DVD, Kassette oder sonstiges.
Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, als die Zweitverwertung komplett weglassen, weil die Zweitverwertung ist gleichzeitig Werbung für die Leute, die das gemacht haben. Wenn die Leute sich einen coolen Film zu Hause angucken und dann der selbe Regisseur einen neuen Film rausbringt im Kino, dann gehen die natürlich ins Kino.
Ich würde sogar so weit gehen zu sagen, das Kino wird die Zweitverwertung sein. Weil nämlich der Zugriff auf den Film selber, den wirst du an deinem Computer haben.
Genau, die Filmproduzenten werden die Refinanzierung über Aktienbeteiligung an Herstellern von Heimvideoanlagen, Begräbenen, Sofas und Popcornmaschinen machen. Aber apropos Popcornmaschinen, wir haben jetzt ohne Hände noch eine Viertelstunde.
Ja, die Hörer beschweren sich auch schon, dass wir sie nicht mehr durchstellen.
Vielleicht noch mal ein, zwei Hörer, dann würde ich...
Wir müssen halt ganz ehrlich sagen, dass wir uns selber so viel interessanter finden.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Bei mir schon.
Ich finde es nicht interessanter.
Ich finde mich und euch interessanter.
Nicht mich.
Mich kenne ich ja. Ach, in den letzten 35 Jahren mit mir gelangweilt. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da? Siehst du, und wenn sie da dran... Ah, hallo. Das ist ein schöner Name. Reiner. Was hast du? Reiner, hallo.
Ihr hört euch ja schrottig an, die Leitung.
Was hörst du denn? Real Audio oder?
Real Audio, ja, so hört sich's an. 16 Bit, nee, 3 Kilohertz glaube ich sind das.
Naja, aber...
2, 5 Kilohertz.
Aber zumindest bekommst du alles mit.
Ja.
Immerhin.
Über Radio.
Wo bist du denn?
Ich bin in F-Hain.
Wo ist das?
Das ist in Rittrishain, Berlin, Mitte.
Da kannst du ja auch dein Radio einschalten.
Nee, aber dann gibt's nachher die Rückkopplung. Warte mal, das ist aus Cottbus vielleicht.
Lieber nicht, ist so. Du hast 3, 1 Kilohertz. Das geht auch noch.
Doch, jetzt geht's. Ihr könnt noch den Kopf heraussetzen, aber dann hab ich wieder den Stereo-Effekt. Ist ganz schrecklich, meine Stimme.
Ja, was möchtest du uns mitteilen?
Ich hab mal eine DVD gesehen. Die war eigentlich ganz nett. Mir hat optisch, hat mir DVD schon gefallen.
Also, jetzt mal Spaß beiseite. Hast du wirklich einen Unterschied gesehen? Hast du gesagt, boah, was für eine Qualität?
Nee, es hat eigentlich eher mehr geflimmert. Wenn man genau hingeguckt hat, fand ich es eigentlich nicht. Da find ich Kinoqualität immer noch besser.
Hast du das auf dem Computer geguckt oder mit so einem richtigen DVD-Player?
Über einen Monitor mit einem DVD-Player, ja, ja. Und einer richtigen ATI-Karte, Grafikkarte.
Wenn du das auf so einem richtigen käuflichen DVD-Player guckst, den du an den Fernseher anschließt, dann sieht das schon richtig gut aus.
Ja, man muss auch dazu sagen, dass die Encoding-Unterschiede gewaltig sind. Ich glaube gerade dieses Stanley Kubrick CD war erstaunlich schlecht codiert.
Ja, richtig. Wir hatten auch Probleme mit dem Ländercode. Man muss den dann ständig umstellen oder so, weil sonst setzt irgendwann das...
Wie, du hast den Ländercode umgestellt?
Nee, nee, das kann man ja nicht. Das geht ja eigentlich nicht, darf man auch nicht.
Rainer, ich mach mal noch ein bisschen weiter, weil wir nur noch ganz...
Halt, ich hab ja noch was. Ich hab eine Internet-Set-Topbox. Da bin ich auch mal drauf hängen geblieben. Also ohne Spaß, ich hab mir das mal angeguckt. War nicht so toll, fand ich.
Ach so, du meinst Internet übers Fernsehen?
Ja, nicht Internet übers Fernsehen so ähnlich. Das ist so eine Set-Topbox, um sich halt über den Fernseher sozusagen ins Internet einzulehnen, ja.
Ja, also genau das, was ich gerade mal gesagt hab. Rainer, ich sag dir trotzdem schon mal Tschüss, weil wir jetzt so noch so wenig Zeit haben. Internet im Fernsehen ist ganz toll, hatte ich mal in einem Hotel. Da plötzlich eine Tastatur auf diesem kleinen Fernseher. Ich sagte, yes, auf der Kopfkiste lag die. Internet, 15 Mark pro Stunde, super. Ich dachte, scheißegal, muss ich's sehen. Und das war wirklich großartig, ein Netzcape auf so einem kleinen Fernseher zu sehen. Irgendwie war es natürlich überhaupt nichts mehr. Du erkennst nichts, gar nichts mehr. Ja, ach, die Einwahl hat glaube ich 10 Minuten gedauert.
Das hat ein Arbeitgeber bezahlt.
Zum Region-Code muss man aber was sagen. Das ist ausnahmsweise ein Fall, wo es tatsächlich nicht illegal ist, den Region-Code seines Players zu ändern. Sondern es hat nur der Hersteller dieses Players unterschrieben, damit er das DVD-Logo da vorne drauf tun kann und damit er sagen kann, sein Player kann DVDs abspielen, dass er dann Region-Code einbaut. Es ist mit nichtem Verbot, ihn auszubauen.
Zwei Anrufer würde ich sagen noch in dieser Sendung, in dieser Ausgabe vom Chaosradio. Einmal Joshi aus Kreuzberg.
Ich bin's, Joshi. Ich hab da so leichte Probleme mit diesen rechtlichen Grundsätzen. Ich hab jetzt...
Das haben wir alle.
Ja, ein Schrieb vorliegen und hier steht Folgendes. Die Verantwortlichkeit der Internetaktiven wird künftig folgendermaßen abgesteckt. Wer eigene Inhalte bereitstellt, ist verantwortlich, das ist in Ordnung, ne?
Was war jetzt?
Wer eigene Inhalte bereitstellt, ist verantwortlich. Und dann steht da unter, wer fremde Inhalte bereithält, den trifft eine Mitverantwortung.
Wo kommt das her?
Wenn ihm der Inhalt bekannt ist und es ihm technisch möglich und zumutbar ist, ein kriminelles Angebot zu sperren.
Könnte das sein, dass du gerade das Tele-Dienste-Gesetz zitierst?
Multimedia-Gesetze.
Der letzte Satz war nicht so komplett falsch, oder?
Nee, der ist richtig. Wie willst du kriminell definieren?
Nach geltendem Recht?
Wenn du was auf deinen Server packst, was dir nicht gehört, zum Beispiel MP3, dann machst du dich strafbar, dann machst du dich mitverantwortlich für das, was passiert, wenn jemand das runterlädt.
Deswegen wechseln wir auch ständig, ne?
Es gab gerade einen Freispruch für einen 17-jährigen Schüler, der links zu illegalen MP3-Fails hatte.
Das war in Schweden.
War heise.de, Newstaker.
Aber die schwedische Gesetzgebung, der Fall sieht im Detail so aus, er ist freigesprochen worden, direkt kriminelle Behandlung gegangen zu haben. Und dann haben sie aber einen neuen Verfahren abgemacht, wegen Unterstützung einer kriminellen Behandlung dazu. Es ist nämlich nach der dortigen Gesetzgebung, musst du immer irgendwie einen Gesetz versprochen pro Verfahren abhandeln oder so. Also das ist insofern...
Also ich würde es niemandem raten.
Ja, das ist auch ganz klar. Ich sag dir auch schon mal Tschüss, Tjoschi. Tschüssi. Dieser Satz mit, wenn ihm bewusst ist und bla, und wenn er das verhindern könnte, ist doch ganz klar. Also du kannst auch sagen, Aldi hat doch genug. Was macht's, wenn ich eine Flasche Champagner klaue? Also das ist irgendwie die alte Diskussion.
Die sehr schwierige Diskussion. Ja, aber dann hat Aldi aber auch eine Flasche Champagner weniger.
Ich erwähne absichtlich den Champagner bei Aldi.
Dann hat ja nicht der Filmvertrieb eine Scheibe weniger.
Aber eben, das ist ja...
Aber einer rechnet natürlich als... Also, eine völlig Quatsch, eine völlig trustige Rechnung. Aber er sagt natürlich, wenn derjenige nicht die Kopie hätte, hätte er das Original kaufen müssen. Also, gib mir Umsatzflöten.
So leben doch, so leben doch, das haben wir doch gehabt, so leben doch irgendwie die Studios. Wenn irgendwie 20 Millionen auf der Welt den Film geguckt haben, dann haben sie ihr Geld eingenommen. Aber sie haben garantiert, dass 20 Millionen Mal der Film kontrolliert, zu dem Zuschauer gekommen ist. Sie haben da überall den Daumen drauf gehabt. Wenn es der Zuschauer eine Kopie macht von dem Film und verteilt sie selbst, gehen ihnen die 10 Zuschauer, die die Kopie sehen, flöten. Das heißt, die gucken sie nicht. Dadurch werden insgesamt weniger Leute den Film gucken. Und das ist ein Problem.
Aber das Problem hätten wir dann schon mit Videorekordern. Weil ich glaube nicht, dass diese von diesen 10 Leuten alle 10 den Film geguckt hätten, wenn sie nicht die Kopie gehabt hätten. Ich glaube, es wäre höchstens einer gewesen.
Videorekorder sind analog. Du kannst von Video nicht beliebig viele Kopien machen. Freunde von mir haben Filme, die hätte ich auch unglaublich gerne, aber die sind in einer derartig miesen Qualität auf diesen VR-Stapes drauf, dass ich eine Kopie davon garantiert nicht mehr tragen würde.
Ja, aber das ist dann auch wirklich so zweite, dritte Generation.
Bei Digital hattest du noch die 20. Generation.
Aber ist das wirklich der Grund? Also ich hab noch nie einen Film nicht gesehen, weil mir die Qualität so schlecht war. Ich schon. Ich hab den ersten Star Wars, der mal rauskam, abgefilmt gesehen und das war schlecht.
Ich hab den neuen Star Wars nicht ganz geguckt, weil irgendwann fand ich ihn dann so langweilig und da war so schlechte Qualität.
Also ich kann mich noch gut erinnern, wie dann so Heavy Metal oder Up in Smoke oder Blues Brothers auf Video zirkulierte. Und zwar so in sechster, siebter, achter Generation. Und das konnte man nicht mehr gucken.
Und hast du es geguckt? So, letzte Anrufer. Wolfgang aus Rosenheim. Hallo.
Hallo Leute.
Rosenheim ist auch in Bayern?
Der weiteste Hörer, du bist es.
Du hast gewonnen. Du bist Hörer der Woche.
Ich wollte nur sagen, die D-Box wird eigentlich grundsätzlich verdammt unterschätzt.
Ja, die D-Box ist super.
Ich hab sie natürlich schön getunt mit der Ur-Flau-Software, mit der DVB 2000. Und man kann also Audio grabben, Video grabben, es läuft alles wunderbar.
Cool, und was hast du schon so aufgenommen?
Eigentlich nur so Teststücke hauptsächlich, weil ich meistens was anderes mache mit der D-Box.
Was machst du denn sonst mit der D-Box?
Bisschen Software schreiben dafür, für die DVB 2000.
Er wollte sich leider nur beim Hintergrund halten. Ich hatte ihn für die Sendung eigentlich eingeladen, aber das vielleicht nochmal kurz für die Hörer, die das jetzt noch nicht ganz auf dem Zeiger haben. Also die D-Box ist natürlich auch nur ein Computer, die halt auch noch mit Software läuft. Und es gibt zwar die von Beta Research, dem sozusagen Konstrukteurbüro der D-Box herausgebende Software, aber die hat eben viele Features nicht. Und es gibt jemanden, der sich da sehr reingekniet hat und der im Grunde genommen gezeigt hat, dass man mit so einer D-Box mit so einem Computer richtig lustige Dinge tun kann. Und das ist der Oberpfau.
Und der heißt?
Lass mal das.
Das ist alles öffentlich bekannt und also die ganze UL und alles, das findet man im Internet. Das ist ein ganz offizielles Projekt. Also da ist nichts hackertechnisch dahinter. Aber diese Software holt halt schon so 90% aus der D-Box raus.
Glaubst du denn, dass die Leute jetzt anfangen, sich Overflow auf ihre Boxen zu spielen und irgendwie Premiere World aufnehmen?
Das glaube ich eher weniger. Also zum Aufnehmen würde ich nicht sagen. Also der Preis pro CD und der Preis pro Speicherplatz, der ist doch immens dann. Also die Datenmenge ist gewaltig. Also das sind doch, wie weiß ich, 3 Megabit.
Ja und wenn ich ein DVD-Rolling, so wie ein CD-Rolling heute 2 Mark kosten würde?
Ja, DVD-Rolling, dann wär's natürlich schon interessanter. Wenn endlich dieses Windows oder die anderen Betriebssysteme, die 2 GB Grenze nicht hätten. Das ist natürlich dann die andere Geschichte wieder.
Na bei DVDs wird das so gelöst, dass man das in GB Blöcke aufspaltet. Also das ist eigentlich kein Problem.
Nee, also wie gesagt, die D-Box, die so in der Art ist, ist ja schon ordentlich. Mit der kann man was machen. Es macht Spaß mit der zu arbeiten.
Ja, ne, die neue D-Box wird auch ziemlich gut. Also ich hab die D-Box 2 gesehen auf der IFA. Da läuft ein Java-EPG drauf, ist ein richtig schneller Prozessor drin. Und also Kirch konvergiert sehr stark irgendwie Richtung MHP. Ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit. Und er hat eine richtig coole Box draußen.
Ja, also die Box, die war recht interessant. Also die haben uns auch genauer angeschaut. Das hat anscheinend auch Beta Research gut gefallen. Die haben gleich ein Foto von uns gemacht.
Ja, seid ihr denn so besonders aus?
Wie bitte?
Seid ihr denn so besonders aus?
Eigentlich nicht.
Habt ihr den Stand mit dem Pinguin gesehen?
Mit dem Pinguin?
Ja, gegenüber vom Beta Research.
Da war glaube ich Europe Online oder irgendein Sky-Anbieter.
Ja, so ein fetter Stand.
Wolfgang, ich sag dir einen schönen Abend, ja?
Ja, wir sollten jetzt vielleicht die gerade verbleibende eine Minute...
Dazu nutzen wir alle Kontaktmöglichkeiten.
Genau, wenn ihr mehr über diesen Unsinn erfahren wollt, macht Internet www.ccc.de. Wir haben einen Kongress hier in Berlin vom 27. bis 29. Dezember im Haus am Kölnischen Park. Das ist also in der Gegend von der Janowitzbrücke.
Das war letztes Mal auch in Berlin.
Genau, krieg ihr auch auf www.ccc.de slash Kongress. Ich glaube, es gibt zur Radiosendung hier noch irgendwie eine URL mit weiteren Verweisen.
Chaosradio.ccc.de ist auf jeden Fall alles über Chaosradio. Da wird auch bald stehen, worum es nächstes Mal geht.
Ansonsten natürlich www.fritz.de für das Live-Hören dieser Sendung, was wir heute gar nicht erwähnt haben. Kann man nämlich natürlich auch im Netz hören. Wir hatten es bei ein paar Hörern. Und unter fritz.de auch immer aktuelle Informationen zu dieser Sendung, Archive und so weiter und so fort. Achso, und die Mail-Adresse ist chaosradio, ne chaos.orb.de, da kommt man dann an, so gut wie alle Leute, die diese Sendung machen. Andi, guckst du mal, du kriegst das nicht?
Doch, doch, doch. Ja, ne, ich guck nur insofern mal. Mein Mailvolumen, seit ich irgendwie auf so einer anderen Mailingliste noch bin, jetzt über 200 Mails am Tag liegen und irgendwann wird's dann doch schwierig.
Ich hab halt was Großartiges bekommen, nämlich den Eintrag in so eine Musik-Mailingliste, wo ich mich natürlich nie eingetragen hab. Dann die zweite, dritte, vierte Mail, wo dann auch drin steht, wie man da unsubscriben kann. Geht natürlich nur über eine Webpage, gehst du zur Webpage, gibst deine E-Mail-Adresse an, das Passwort, was sie dir geschickt haben, gibt's nicht den User. Stattdessen krieg ich irgendwie täglich 10 Mails von dieser beschissenen Mailingliste. Was wir brauchen sind...
Filter.
Filter, ganz viel Filter, automatische Filter und private E-Mail-Adressen.
Das ist dann auch das andere Kapitel, was kommt, wenn jeder einen Fernsehsender hat, dann wird das Kapitel Medienkompetenz, glaube ich, auch nochmal in den eigenen Fernsehsender.
Im nächsten Monat, am letzten Mittwoch des Monats November, feiern wir 4 Jahre Chaosradio.
Macht euch gefasst, schneidet euch an.
Haben dann 12 Leute im Studio und betrinken uns alle. Oder irgendwie sowas. Das ist der Chaosradio bei Fritz.
Zwei, drei, vier.
Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Viel Spaß mit Martin Petershoff, der macht den Nightflight. Das war der CCC, DJ Claude und Johnny.